Okay, this is Jason.
I'm doing a cold open.
I'm real snacky.
It's carbohydrates.
They're crunchy.
They're salty.
They're not good for me.
But man, it feels good.
好吧，我是杰森。我在做一个开场白。我真的很想吃零食。是碳水化合物。它们是脆的。它们是咸的。它们对我没好处。但天哪，感觉真好。
Doesn't it feel good, gang,
to do a nice, crunchy, salty snack?
Or do you like the gooey, sweet ones?
I don't know.
Maybe a combo of both is great, right?
But what do you start with?
Which do you end with?
What do you put in between?
不觉得很好吗，各位，吃一个又脆又咸的零食？还是你们喜欢黏糊糊的甜食？我不知道。也许两者的结合很棒，对吧？但你从什么开始？你以什么结束？你在中间放什么？
I know what you put in between.
and you put in a nice big, fat, well-cooked episode of Smartless.
Numb-Num-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-W.
Welcome to SmartLus.
Smart.
Stress.
You know, guys, I can't have the stress.
I lost my voice, and it's just now come back a little bit.
我知道你在中间放什么。你会放一集精彩、丰盛、制作精良的《Smartless》。Numb-Num-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-W。欢迎来到SmartLus。Smart。Stress。你知道的，伙计们，我承受不了压力。我失声了，现在才刚恢复了一点。
I still have a little brand of car.
Are you screaming at people on set?
Is it from the Knicks games?
Or is you screaming at people on set again?
I think it was, it was a, it was a.
I want my chair over here.
My chair.
It was, I think it was a cold
我还有点像个车牌。你在片场对别人尖叫吗？是因为尼克斯队的比赛吗？还是你又在片场对别人尖叫了？我想是，是一个，是一个。我想要我的椅子放在这儿。我的椅子。那是一个，我想那是一场感冒
or it might have been allergies.
No.
I mean, yeah.
By yourself?
It started, yeah.
It started in my throat
and it went to my nose
and then it landed on my vocal cords.
或者可能是过敏。不。我是说，对。你自己吗？它开始于，对。它先是在我喉咙，然后到了鼻子，最后落在了我的声带上。
You're a little,
Jason's a little fragile.
I feel like this is the first time
we're meeting the real J.B. right now.
And I was a little frazzled
getting to Mike today
because that's what we call it, right?
Getting to Mike.
你有点，杰森有点脆弱。我觉得这好像是我们第一次见到真正的J.B.。我今天去见迈克的时候有点心神不定，因为我们是这么叫的，对吧？去见迈克。
Because I wanted to have my teeth brushed
for you.
Do you guys brush your teeth for me?
Of course, always.
No, not me.
You don't.
Don't you, bro, look at his teeth.
去见迈克。因为我想为你把牙齿刷干净。你们会为我刷牙吗？当然，总是会。不，我不会。你不会。你不会吗，兄弟，看他的牙齿。
Did you sleep with a whitener on too long last night?
No, I went to the, look at that.
I went to the dentist yesterday, and he's like, I don't wipe my teeth.
How about that?
And you smoke.
And you drink coffee.
I know.
And you self-tan.
你昨晚是不是用美白剂睡得太久了？不，我去，看那个。我昨天去了牙医那儿，他说，我不擦牙齿。怎么样？而且你抽烟。而且你喝咖啡。我知道。而且你还自己做美黑。
I thought, don't self-tan.
That's the one where don't make me mad.
You and Kimmel.
Nobody loves hitting me.
me my tan more than Molly.
Wait, what self-tan mean?
You just lays out.
That's like a cream.
我想，别自己做美黑。那是让我生气的事。你和吉米。没有人比莫莉更喜欢打击我、打击我的美黑了。等等，美黑是什么意思？你就是躺在那儿。那就像是一种乳霜。
But where do you find the time and how is it always so even, Mr. Trump?
Well, you know, you know what I do every day.
I do my walk every day.
And so that's like an hour.
I don't talk to me like I'm fucking watching you doing your fucking heavy hands and shit.
You know what my roots are your Velcro ankle weights.
You know my room too.
Is it?
但是你在哪里找到的时间，而且怎么总是这么匀称，川普先生？嗯，你知道，你知道我每天做什么。我每天都去散步。所以大概有一个小时。别跟我说话，好像我他妈在看你做你那该死的手部负重之类的东西。你知道我的根源是你的魔术贴脚踝负重沙袋吗？你也知道我的房间。是吗？
With my weight best.
Somebody took a picture of me with my hair.
weight vest yesterday on Loma Vye.
Oh, really?
I got to see that.
But Will, I spend a lot of time when I'm not working on the golf course, as we're aware.
What?
That's five hours of sun exposure, and I wear 100.
带着我的负重背心。昨天有人在洛马维亚拍了张我穿着负重背心的照片。哦，真的吗？我得看看那个。但是威尔，当我不工作时，我花了很多时间在高尔夫球场上，这是众所周知的。什么？那是五个小时的日晒，我涂了100倍防晒霜。
So you're saying you're 20-minute...
I don't wear.
Okay, that's what it is.
A, and B, I don't wear a bucket hat.
Right.
So you wear no sun protection whatsoever.
You're kind of bragging about that right now to get yourself that nice color,
but you're giving yourself fucking cancer.
所以你是说你那20分钟的……我不涂。好吧，就是这样。A，还有B，我不戴渔夫帽。对。所以你根本不做任何防晒。你现在有点在为这个吹嘘，为了让自己拥有那种好看的肤色，但你却在给自己搞出该死的癌症。
I'm not, first of all,
fucking cool it.
It's early for me to die, okay?
I've had skin cancer already.
I had something shaved off my eye.
Remember that?
Yeah, I do.
Go in there and got it all scraped off.
我没有，首先，他妈的冷静点。我死还为时过早，好吗？我已经得过皮肤癌了。我眼睛上有个东西被刮掉了。还记得吗？对，我记得。进去然后把它们全刮掉了。
I get checked.
I have a friend of mine,
and she's been giving me a lot of shit
about sunscreen lately.
Are these checks that you pay for,
or is it,
you say a friend?
Like a close friend of mine.
我去做检查。我有个朋友，她最近一直在为防晒霜的事给我找麻烦。这些检查是你自费的，还是你说的朋友？就像我一个很亲密的朋友。
Does she check for ticks
at the same time and all those tough to find spots.
We've found another one.
She just squeezes it out.
Like a zip.
You're covered in ticks.
I found a couple of leeches too.
I'm like, so?
她顺便检查有没有壁虱吗，还有那些很难找到的部位。我们又发现了一个。她直接把它挤出来。就像挤青春痘一样。你身上到处都是壁虱。我还发现了几只水蛭。我心想，所以呢？
They have to remove the poison.
The ticks and the tick.
Oh my gosh.
So wait, so you've got a, yeah, now you're getting into a sweat
because you're thinking about all the possible risks you're taking.
I've also had four coffees today.
so having a coffee sweat.
Yeah.
它们必须清除毒素。壁虱和那个壁虱。哦天哪。所以等等，所以你有一个，是的，现在你开始冒汗了，因为你在想你正在承担的所有可能风险。我今天还喝了四杯咖啡。所以这是喝咖啡引起的出汗。是的。
You know, we were at dinner the other night, J.B., you were missed.
I know.
You were missed.
And Jen brought a photo up from our big family trip
from a few years back where we went with all the kids and everything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
God, I love that, too.
And there was a photo of all of us,
你知道，前几天我们在吃晚饭，J.B.，大家很想念你。我知道。大家很想念你。简拿出了一张我们几年前那次大家庭旅行的照片，当时我们带着所有的孩子一起去的。对，对，对。天哪，我也喜欢那个。然后有一张我们所有人的照片，
and then my head sticking out in the back.
Remember how ten I was?
And my hair is sticking up.
And then I've got zinc on my lips,
and I look like a crazy person, right, John?
I looked like that.
We passed around the back.
photo and everybody had something to say about it and I've never seen it before I was like what is I look like I look like you look like you look like a predator like
接着我的头从后面伸出来。记得我当时晒得有多黑吗？我的头发竖着。然后我的嘴唇上涂了氧化锌，我看起来像个疯子，对吧，约翰？我看起来就是那样。我们在后方传看这张照片，每个人对它都有话说，我以前从来没见过，当时我就想，那是什么？我看起来像，我看起来像，你看起来像个掠夺者，就像
like you guys came to the island and found me there like I'd laid out you know I'd written in the sand sOS we have to go back there I know back guys it'd be fun to go now with the kids a little bit older before how's it night it's it's fun being back for the weekend yeah very nice to be back for the weekend yeah I'm going to your Q&A jay at tomorrow at Netflix because I want to I know that you're doing a Q&A session right hey what
What are you doing there?
I'm just going to go, because I want to ask you questions about directing and stuff.
I know you're getting a good thing.
And so I got an email from Netflix about it.
Like, come join us.
I'm like, oh, I'm coming.
Wear the zinc on your nose so that when you pulled your hand out.
就像你们来到岛上在那儿发现了我就像我躺在沙滩上写着SOS我们得回去了我知道回去吧伙计们孩子们大一点了再去会挺有意思的周末回来感觉怎么样？周末回来感觉真好，是的，明天我会在网飞（Netflix）参加你的问答环节，杰，因为我想去，我知道你要举办一个问答会，嘿，你在那儿干什么？我只是要去，因为我想问你关于导演之类的问题。我知道你有一个不错的项目。所以我收到了网飞（Netflix）关于这事的电子邮件。就像，来加入我们吧。我就想，哦，我要去。在鼻子上涂上氧化锌，这样当你把手拿出来的时候。
I'm going to put a fake mustache and a hat.
And then I'm going to sit in the back.
And I'm going, I've got a question.
No, you should play the crazy Italian guy from our podcast.
Yeah.
I love a black rabbit.
What is your, these brothers are crazy.
You're unheed.
我要戴上假胡子和帽子。然后我要坐在后面。然后我要说，我有一个问题。不，你应该扮演我们播客里的那个疯狂的意大利人。我喜欢黑兔子。你的什么，这些兄弟太疯狂了。你真放肆。
I can't believe they sent you an invite.
No, actually, a different friend of mine got an email about it,
and they sent it to me.
And I was like, oh, fucking send me that.
I want to go.
I want to go show up and crash.
How good.
And then, you know what?
我真不敢相信他们给你发了邀请函。不，其实，我另一个朋友收到了关于这个的电子邮件，然后他们转发给我了。当时我就想，哦，他妈的发给我吧。我想去。我想去现身并大闹一场。多好啊。然后，你知道吗？
I did have the thought.
I was like, if I did it, then I make it about me.
And I'm not going to go and do that.
No, why do that?
Please, please, please, do it enough.
There's so many people listening right now who are nodding going.
I know.
You do make it about you shut up.
我确实有过这种想法。我想，如果我去了，那我就会把焦点变成我自己。我才不会去干那种事。不，干嘛要那样？求求你，求求你，求求你，去做吧。现在有好多人在听，都在点头说。我知道。你确实把焦点变成了你自己，闭嘴吧。
We hate your stupid stories.
But what about, like, yeah, so I'm here this weekend.
to do these interviews and stuff for DTF and for Black Rabbit and stuff.
And it's all talking.
It's all talking.
You're going to make it.
Including this podcast.
And I was looking at literally 36 hours ago, I couldn't, I couldn't.
我们讨厌你的那些蠢故事。但是，比如，是的，所以我这个周末在这里是为了做这些采访，为了《DTF》和《黑兔子》之类的。这全都是在聊天。全都是在聊天。你会成功的。包括这个播客。我看着，就在36小时前，我不能，我不能。
Everything was like this.
I couldn't make a set.
And I was like, oh, my God, I've got like five days of work ahead of me that's just talking.
Luckily, I got a little prednisone in me and an antipot.
Yeah, good.
You know what?
I was talking to our buddy who's doing.
dog day afternoon, not John Brunthal,
一切都像这样。我发不出声音。当时我想，天哪，我接下来的五天工作全都是在说话。幸好我吃了一点强的松，还用了一点喷雾。对，很好。你知道吗？我当时在跟我们的哥们说话，他在排演《热天午后》，不是约翰·博恩瑟（John Bernthal），
but I was talking to, you guys know John Ortiz
is the best, he's a great actor
and he's a good buddy mine.
And he is on Broadway right now,
and he has a really bad cold,
and it's a night, he's like,
it's a nightmare scenario.
I almost called you, Sean,
我是说，你们知道约翰·奥提兹（John Ortiz）是最棒的，他是个伟大的演员，也是我的好哥们。他现在正在百老汇演出，他得了很重的感冒，那是晚上，他说，这简直是噩梦般的场景。我差点就打电话给你了，肖恩，
because I knew you'd probably have some,
like, fancy Broadway doctor
that knows how to deal with vocal,
vocal stuff.
Always, I have, too,
the best.
Boots, boots, I'll text you.
Boots.
因为我知道你可能有什么百老汇的高档医生，知道怎么处理声带、声带方面的问题。总是这样，我也有，最好的。靴子，靴子，我发短信给你。靴子。
Boots, no.
Wait, wait, is that,
is that, wait, Sean,
are you getting rid of peasant?
battles and co-ing with boots right now he's boots right now he's boots oh boots mcgee yeah and boots
yeah because of a boot on um but uh speaking of some's got a point that he wants to make i saw him
who are you looking at off camera who's giving you the cue to go into it is this guy no nobody me it's
i'm looking at all of you no we have to go because our guest is super famous and she has to work
靴子，不。等等，等等，那是，那是，等等，肖恩，你现在是在摆脱平民之争，改用“靴子”这个词吗？他现在是靴子，现在他是靴子，哦，靴子麦吉，是的，还有靴子，因为有个靴子在……但是，说到有人有个观点想表达，我看到他了，你在看镜头外面谁？谁在给你切入的 cue？是这家伙吗？不，没人，是我，我在看着你们所有人，不，我们得走了，因为我们的嘉宾超级有名，她还得工作。
oh sorry okay yes here we go here we go so i should have got dressed up i meanwhile got undressed
put your sleeves back on it i'm going to put a nice apache me there um
Oh, guys, my guest today, who I love and I live for,
grew up in Castle Hill, New York,
the middle of three sisters in an apartment.
Andrew Martin.
So small, they all shared a bed.
There was always music in the house
哦，抱歉，好吧，是的，我们开始吧，我们开始吧，所以我本该穿好衣服的，我却把衣服脱了，把袖子穿回去，我要在那儿放一个漂亮的阿帕奇我……哦，伙计们，我今天的嘉宾，我深爱着她并为她而活，在纽约卡城堡山长大，是公寓里三姐妹中的老二。安德鲁·马丁。太小了，她们挤在一张床上。家里总是放着音乐，
with constant reenactments of West Side Story.
I could do the whole thing with her.
Chenoweth.
But her parents still hoped she'd become a lawyer.
Instead, she left college to pursue dance full-time,
left home and ended up sleeping in a Manhattan dance studio.
Somewhere along the way,
she taught Carrie Washington how to dance.
还不断重现《西区故事》。我可以和她一起演整部剧。切诺维斯（Chenoweth）。但她的父母依然希望她成为一名律师。相反，她离开大学去全职追求舞蹈，离家出走，最后睡在曼哈顿的一个舞蹈室里。在某个时候，她教过凯丽·华盛顿跳舞。
I can't wait to ask.
about that. Then she became the first Latina actress ever paid a million dollars for a movie role.
Bruno Marino.
Briefly been on this podcast before, it's the beautiful, multi-talented and unstoppable.
Jennifer Lopez.
Yes!
The way.
Willie got it.
我迫不及待地想问问那个。然后她成为了历史上第一个因电影角色获得一百万美元片酬的拉丁裔女演员。布鲁诺·玛丽诺。曾短暂上过这个播客，她就是美丽、多才多艺且势不可挡的詹妮弗·洛佩兹。耶！太对了。威利猜对了。
Very nice.
It's for you a few.
No, when you said briefly, and then I remember you briefly on, yes.
I was so close with Andrew Martin. God damn it.
So close.
Oh, my God.
Jen, what are you drinking?
Hi there.
非常好。这是给你的。不，当你说是短暂的时候，然后我想起你短暂地上过，是的。我和安德鲁·马丁太亲近了。该死的。太亲近了。哦，天哪。简，你在喝什么？嗨。
A little cappuccino.
Oh, nice.
What do you go with for the milk on that?
Are we almond?
Are we oats?
I'm traditional.
I like a 2% milk.
I know everybody's with fancy oats and almonds and soy.
一点卡布奇诺。哦，不错。你选的是什么奶？杏仁奶？燕麦奶？我很传统。我喜欢2%的牛奶。我知道每个人都在赶时髦喝燕麦奶、杏仁奶和大豆奶。
Cow milk all the way.
Jason, Jason responds to that, you beta?
I know, but I feel, I got word from one of those doctors back in the day that I'm lactose intolerant or bad with the dairy or something like that.
And so I've just never had like cow milk since it.
Plus, I did see a documentary once where they said the very disgusting fact,
which is humans are the only species that drink the milk of another animal.
I don't care.
That like, it is weird, isn't it?
纯牛奶才是王道。杰森，杰森对这个作何反应，你个β男？我知道，但我感觉，我以前听某个医生说过我有乳糖不耐受，或者对乳制品不耐受之类的话。所以我从此再也没喝过牛奶。另外，我确实看过一部纪录片，里面说了一个非常恶心的事实，那就是人类是唯一会饮用其他动物奶的物种。我不在乎。这听起来很怪，对吧？
It is weird.
I'm the same way.
I don't care.
I know.
You drink full, tall glasses of milk, Sean.
I don't care.
I know.
And it tastes so good.
这很怪。我也一样。我不在乎。我知道。肖恩，你大口大口地喝着满满一杯牛奶。我不在乎。我知道。而且味道太好了。
It tastes so good.
Plus, but Jennifer Lopez is always working out and exercising.
and staying in good health so she can have milk in her coffee.
I try.
Right?
Well, not about that.
It's not about that.
It's not a bad health choice.
味道太好了。另外，但是詹妮弗·洛佩兹一直在健身和锻炼，保持健康，所以她可以在咖啡里加奶。我尽量。对吧？嗯，不只是为了这个。不全是这个。这不是一个不健康的抉择。
But I mean, you know, if you're going to do it, you kind of have to balance it.
Says Jennifer Lopez.
She's Dr. Ding Dong over there.
You look very, very healthy.
Thank you.
Jen, thank you for doing this.
I'm so excited you're here.
This is a long time coming from me.
但我的意思是，你知道，如果你要这样做，你得平衡一下。詹妮弗·洛佩兹如是说。她就是那里的叮咚博士。你看起来非常、非常健康。谢谢。简，谢谢你来做客。我很高兴你来到这里。对我来说，这等待了很久。
You've been on my list since we started.
Oh, you're sweet.
Wow, this is exciting.
It's true.
And I know we kind of know each other.
and I love you too.
Do you?
Yes, we work together many times over the years.
从我们开始起，你就在我的名单上了。哦，你真甜。哇，这太让人兴奋了。是真的。而且我知道我们算得上认识，我也爱你。真的吗？是的，这些年来我们合作过好多次。
Will and Grace.
And the Will and Grace.
And something else, too.
I can't remember what.
Did we?
I think so.
You know what I realized?
I'm so bad that, you know,
《威尔和格蕾丝》。还有《威尔和格蕾丝》。还有其他别的。我不记得是什么了。我们有过吗？我想是的。你知道我意识到什么吗？我太差劲了，以至于，你知道，
you get to a point where you've done so much with so many people.
And people are like, we did that.
Like the other day, don't hate me.
I was watching Monster-in-law.
Oh, my God.
And I forgot you were in.
You are like, what?
I'm going to do that podcast.
你到了一个地步，你和这么多人在这么多项目里合作过。然后别人说，我们合作过那个。就像前几天，别恨我。我在看《怪兽岳母》。哦，天哪。我忘了你在里面了。你就像是，什么？我要去做那个播客。
No, no, because it was just so long ago.
I mean, I don't want to say how many years ago it was, but it was so long ago.
Wasn't that during the rest of development, Willie?
You did that?
It was 21 years ago.
It was the summer of 2005.
21 years ago.
You know, Jennifer, as I'm admiring your beautiful printer in the background there,
不，不，因为那是太久以前的事了。我是说，我不想说那是多少年前的事了，但真的是太久以前了。那不是在《发展受阻》播出的期间吗，威利？你干的？那是21年前。那是2005年的夏天。21年前。你知道，詹妮弗，当我正欣赏你背景里那台美丽的打印机时，
I then noticed that, Sean, you've moved the award.
Didn't you have an award behind you last week?
Yes, because you made fun of me.
And I made funny, you moved it.
Yeah, I did.
But it's just right there, both of them.
But what about how, how, how.
Jen keeps it real.
我突然注意到，肖恩，你把奖杯移走了。你上周身后不是有个奖杯吗？是的，因为你取笑我。我取笑了你，你就把它移走了。对，我移了。但它就在那儿，两个都在。但是，话说回来，简是怎么保持真实自我的？
She's got a fucking printer in the bed right of her frame.
That's a bizhub.
I'm in a hotel.
You are?
Where?
In New York?
I was here for the upfront.
So I'm just here.
她镜头正后方竟然有一台他妈的打印机。那是美能达（Bizhub）一体机。我在酒店里。你在哪儿？在纽约？我来这里是为了推介会（Upfronts）。所以我只是在这儿。
No, but you know,
you know,
people like stack their awards behind them
when they do zooms?
Yeah, I do.
Yeah.
No, you don't.
But I, in my office at home,
不，但你知道，你知道，人们在做Zoom时会在身后叠放奖杯吗？是的，我叠过。是的。不，你没有。但我在我家里的办公室里，
I have like a wall of all these awards and things.
All behind you for the ZZE.
They're just there.
And then you sit at your desk and they're there.
You've got so many.
You can't point the camera.
Where are you going to put them?
Exactly.
我有一面墙挂满了所有这些奖杯和东西。都在你身后为了ZZE。它们就在那儿。然后你坐在你的办公桌前，它们就在那儿。你实在太多了。你都不能把镜头对准它们。你打算把它们放在哪儿？ exactamente（恰好）。
Jason, where are you going to put them in your office there?
Or, yeah.
By the way, they're in the basement now.
Will's looking behind him.
He can't fit him in the whisper booth.
I can't.
There's not one.
杰森，你打算把它们放在你那儿的办公室里吗？或者，是的。顺便说一句，它们现在在地下室了。威尔正在身后寻找。他把它塞不进耳语隔间。塞不进。根本没有。
Why is it so dark in there?
I know.
So that his tan pops.
This is my booth.
But hang on a second.
I'm a shirt.
He's getting a nice bounce off his teeth, though.
The shorts.
为什么里面这么黑？我知道。这样他的美黑效果才显眼。这是我的隔间。但等一下。我是一件衬衫。不过他的牙齿反射出不错的光芒。短裤。
I know.
The shorts.
Like at what age do you stop wearing shorts?
First of all.
Look at these.
Oh, it's a hockey glove.
These are special Toronto Maple Leaf, limited Toronto Maple Leafs.
When are the Toronto Maple Leafs ever had a green hockey glove?
我知道。短裤。你到什么年龄就不再穿短裤了？首先。看看这些。哦，这是一个冰球手套。这是特别版多伦多枫叶队，限量版多伦多枫叶队。多伦多枫叶队什么时候有过绿色的冰球手套？
It used to be the Toronto St. Pat's when they first started.
And then look at this. Jason, do you remember this?
I've somehow kept this after all these years.
What is it?
Is that the Wanamaker from the PGA Championship?
It's called the VH1.
Oh, boy.
Big in 04.
他们刚开始的时候是多伦多圣帕特里克队。然后看这个。杰森，你还记得这个吗？我不知怎么地把这个保留了这么多年的。这是什么？那是PGA锦标赛的沃纳马克奖杯吗？它叫VH1。哦，天哪。04年的大奖。
And we got it.
We went for arrested and somehow I've kept this stupid huge trophy.
Wait, so we got one trophy and you got to keep it?
Yeah, obviously, everybody elected.
me because they were like, who's the most deserving?
Is VH1 still going?
I don't know.
Yeah, I think so.
我们拿到了。我们去参加 arrested（《发展受阻》剧组聚会）然后不知怎么我留下了这个蠢透了的巨大奖杯。等等，所以我们拿了一个奖杯然后你把它留下了？对，很显然，大家都选了我，因为他们觉得，谁最配得上？VH1还在播吗？我不知道。对，我想是的。
Hey, Sean, welcome to the show.
Yeah, question for the guest, please, Sean.
No, not at all.
Got to break in.
Let's just chit-chat.
Well, it's, you know, but it's the thing about, like,
we worked together three times,
and Will and Grace.
嘿，肖恩，欢迎来到节目。是的，请问嘉宾一个问题，肖恩。不，完全没有。得插话。我们随便聊聊吧。嗯，你知道，但这就是那回事，比如，我们合作过三次，还有《威尔和格蕾丝》。
And by the first time, God, did we laugh a lot?
I mean, I was kicking you in,
literally, physically kicking you in the ass,
jumping in between your legs,
and, like, dancing.
like fools. It was ridiculously hilarious.
And you were so game.
And I think you're so game for so many things.
第一次的时候，天哪，我们笑了多少次？我是说，我当时在踢你，真的，身体上踢你的屁股，跳进你的双腿之间，像傻子一样跳舞。简直滑稽透了。而且你太配合了。我觉得你对好多事情都超级配合。
And, you know, in researching...
Yeah, too many things sometimes.
No, no, no. But, but, you know, in doing all this research before today, you realize,
oh, I don't really...
I've never done a deep dive on you.
We always have chit chat and have a good time, you know, in lap off.
You never asked her anything important.
You were just worried about yourself.
而且，你知道，在做研究时……是的，有时候太多事情了。不，不，不。但是，但是，你知道，在今天之前做所有这些研究时，你意识到，哦，我其实从没有……我从来没有对你进行过深入的了解。我们总是闲聊，玩得很开心，你知道，笑个不停。你从来没问过她任何重要的事情。你只关心你自己。
That's right. I was always like, when's the next question about me?
But so before we get into it, I just...
I just want to say, I realize doing all this stuff,
how rare your kind of drive is,
your work ethic, the ambition, the discipline.
You've been doing at such a high level for decades.
I mean, have you seen her documentary?
That documentary is just like,
没错。我总是像，下一个关于我的问题是什么时候？但在我们深入探讨之前，我只想……我只想说，我通过做所有这些事情意识到，你的这种干劲是多么罕见，你的职业道德、野心、纪律性。你已经以如此高的水平坚持了几十年。我是说，你看过她的纪录片吗？那部纪录片简直就像是，
I think I had a chance to run into you after I saw
and said how much I love it.
It's so impressive.
I mean, not only just well made,
but the scope of it, I mean, your career is incredibly stacked.
It's incredible.
nonstop.
我想我在看完之后有机会遇到你，并说了我有多喜欢它。太令人印象深刻了。我是说，不仅制作精良，而且它的体量，我是说，你的职业生涯简直不可思议。太不可思议了。太不可思议了。从不停歇。
And this is another thing we'll talk about later,
but the thing you do for women in general,
whether you do it intentionally or not,
I'm sure some of it is intentional,
you make them feel empowered,
you show them that talent and beauty and sexuality.
You can have all that at any age,
and you're fearless about all that.
这也是我们稍后会谈到的另一件事，你为广大女性所做的事情，无论你是刻意还是无意，我确信其中有些是刻意的，你让她们感到赋权，你向她们展示了才华、美貌和性感。你可以在任何年龄拥有这一切，而且你对这一切都无所畏惧。
How aware of,
are you aware of how much permission that gives people
or are you too busy working to even think about it?
I'll say this.
When I was starting out, and I had just started doing like my clothing line.
So I had been acting for a while and dancing and singing for a while,
had my first records out and things like that.
So this is, I don't know, 20 years ago.
你有多意识到，你意识到这给了人们多少许可，还是你太忙于工作以至于根本没去想它？我这么说吧。当我刚开始出道时，我刚开始做我的服装系列。所以当时我已经演了一段时间的戏，跳舞唱歌了一段时间，出了我的第一张专辑之类的。所以这是，我不知道，20年。
Yeah.
And I was working with a few girls in my office who are like friends who I just hired.
You know what I mean?
And I remember saying, like it was getting overwhelming.
And I said, I just, this is so fun.
fucking much. Why am I doing this? And she goes, Jennifer, if you can't, and I probably had
just went through some breakup and fucking everything had blown up in my face again. You know what I mean?
I was just like, I just don't know if I can go on. She goes, Jennifer, if you can't do it, none of us
是的。当时我和办公室里的几个女孩一起工作，她们就像是我刚雇的朋友。你知道我的意思吗？我记得当时我说过，这变得让人应接不暇。我说，我只是，这他妈太好玩了。我为什么要这样做？然后她去说，詹妮弗，如果你不能，而且我可能刚经历了一场分手，一切又他妈在我面前炸裂了。你知道我的意思吗？我当时就像，我只是不知道我能不能坚持下去。她说，詹妮弗，如果你做不到，我们谁
can do it. And when she said that to me, I never forgot it. And I thought to myself, oh,
people look at me a certain way, especially girls, like women.
Inspiration for sure
They were like
And it gave me like
A feeling of responsibility
To do things right all the time
A responsibility you like or didn't want
也做不到。当她对我说那番话时，我永远不会忘记。我心里想，哦，人们以某种方式看待我，尤其是女孩，就像女性。这绝对是一种灵感。她们就像……这给了我一种责任感，去把每件事都做好。这种责任感是你喜欢的还是不想承担的？
I don't mind it
Because I am a hard worker
And I do have discipline
Like I started running track when I was
You know
Eight or nine years old
And I was practicing every day
Like I always had kind of like an athlete's kind of drive
我不介意。因为我是一个努力工作的人，我确实很有纪律性。比如我从八九岁的时候就开始练习田径。我每天都在练习，我一直有一种运动员般的干劲
And work ethic
That makes sense
Yeah
And I did track for a while, gymnastics.
I played softball.
Like, I was very much an athlete before I fell in love with dancing.
Once I fell in love with dancing, sports went out the window.
Right, because it is a sport.
和职业道德。这说得通。是的。而且我练了一段时间田径，体操。我打垒球。在爱上跳舞之前，我非常像个运动员。一旦我爱上了跳舞，运动就被抛到九霄云外了。没错，因为它本身就是一项运动。
It is a sport.
And it was just an easy transition.
But also because I grew up on musicals with my mom and all of that.
And I loved them so much.
It was like I always wanted to sing and dance and act.
But when it took its natural time, I really, like, left everything behind and just fell in love with that.
But that really made me feel that that exchange stayed with me even all these years later because it just made me feel like, like don't fuck it up.
Like do the right things.
它就是一项运动。而且这是一个很自然的过渡。但也因为我从小和妈妈一起看音乐剧以及所有这些。我太喜欢它们了。就好像我一直想唱歌、跳舞和演戏。但当它顺其自然到来时，我真的，就像，把一切都抛在脑后，只爱上了那个。但那真的让我觉得，那种交流甚至在多年后依然留在我的记忆中，因为它让我觉得，别搞砸了。把事情做好。
People are watching you for whatever reason, maybe because I was, you know, Puerto Rican and from the Bronx and came from similar places where all these people, you know, people come from.
You know, I wasn't like born in Hollywood and, you know, kind of that thing.
And so there was a real...
Jason.
A real, like, idea in my mind of, like, you have to do things right.
Don't fuck it up, you know?
And work for it.
Yeah.
不管出于什么原因，人们都在看着你，也许是因为我是，你知道的，波多黎各人，来自布朗克斯，来自和所有这些其他人相似的地方。你知道，我不是出生在好莱坞的那种。所以在我脑海里有一个真实的想法，那就是，你必须把事情做好。别搞砸了，你知道吗？并为之努力。是的。
And do it.
Do it.
Like, do the thing.
Like, go for the...
Go for it.
Yeah.
What was first for you?
是的。去做吧。去做那件事。比如，去争取……去争取吧。对。对你来说，什么是开始？
Was it an example of someone who was just an incredible inspiration as far as their accomplishments?
Was that first?
or was it being inspired by seeing an incredible dancer or musician or actor?
When you were a little girl, what was the first thing that inspired you?
Was it accomplishment or was it a specific talent?
No, it was the arts.
From when I was very little, I remember, you bought up Rita Moreno and you bought up West Side Story right before,
as you were trying to guess who I was.
是一个人的榜样，他们在成就方面简直是不可思议的灵感？那是第一位的吗？还是被看到不可思议的舞者、音乐家或演员所启发？当你还是个小女孩时，第一件启发你的事是什么？是成就还是某种特定的才华？不，是艺术。自我很小的时候起，我记得，你刚才在我猜你是谁之前提到了丽塔·莫雷诺（Rita Moreno）和《西区故事》。
That's all he does.
And it really was Reader-Marin.
It really was Rita Moreno for me.
Oh, really?
Yes, yes.
I did want her to be my mom watching an electric company.
I said to my mother once when I was a tiny little kid, I said, I want her to be my mom.
他就会这个。他就会这个。那真的就是丽塔·莫雷诺。对我和来说，那真的就是丽塔·莫雷诺。哦，真的吗？是的，是的。看着《电力公司》（The Electric Company），我真的希望她能成为我的妈妈。当我还是个小不点的时候，我曾对我妈说过，我想让她当我妈。
Yes, who wouldn't?
And she's so amazing.
And the thing is, my mom watched West Side Story in the theater when it first came out.
And she made us watch it every single year.
I don't even remember the first time I saw it.
Three years old, four years old, five years old.
But I do remember watching it on TV one Thanksgiving because it came on one day.
a year and thinking that's what I want to do.
是的，谁不想呢？她太棒了。关键是，我妈当年在电影院里看的首映版《西区故事》。她让我们每年都看一遍。我甚至不记得我第一次看是什么时候了。三岁、四岁、五岁。但我确实记得有一次感恩节在电视上看到它，因为它一年只播一次，当时我就想，那正是我想要做的。
I want to sing and dance and act.
I want to dance around.
My mother was kind of that way as well and very kind of vivacious, takeover the room type
of person.
And I wasn't like that.
I was more like my dad.
I was more quiet and kind of like to myself.
But that part I had.
我想唱歌、跳舞、演戏。我想到处跳舞。我妈妈也是那种人，非常生动活泼，属于那种能掌控全场的人。我不是那样的人。我更像我爸爸。我更安静，更喜欢独处。但我身上也有那一面。
Like I wanted to sing and dance and shake my ass too.
You know what my mom was doing.
You just imagine you dancing and singing around like the living room and stuff like that.
Like all like kids.
kids do because like that's when we have no fear and no sense of you know and like it's like
nobody's watching you mean right but then there's that moment we all hit when we're about i don't know
10 11 or something where you start to become aware of shame and embarrassment and what other people
might be thinking and there's that transition that it's almost a sad transition that you see kids go
就像我也想唱歌、跳舞和扭屁股一样。你知道我妈妈当时在做什么。你只要想象一下你在客厅里跳舞唱歌之类的。就像所有孩子们做的那样，因为那是我们毫无恐惧、没有任何意识的时刻，而且就像没有人看着你，对吧？但随后我们都会迎来这样一个时刻，大概10、11岁左右，你开始对羞耻感、尴尬以及别人可能会怎么想有了意识，然后会经历那样一个转变，那几乎是一个悲伤的转变，你看着孩子们经历
through where they become self-aware but then you know you hope that they gather sort of coping skills
to kind of have self-assuredness
and to kind of push through that
and have their confidence take over
and to be able to push through that.
Do you remember that moment
where you stopped kind of dancing
like no one was watching
自我意识觉醒的过程，但你知道，你希望他们能获得某种应对技巧，从而拥有自信，能够突破自我，让自信心占据主导地位，并能够克服这一切。你还记得你停止了那种“旁若无人地跳舞”的时刻吗？
and you were aware people were watching
and were able to push through that?
I think this is what makes me a little different.
That never happened?
No.
I was never afraid to make a fool of myself.
That's great.
I was always just like, it's fine.
你意识到人们在看着你，并且能够克服那种感觉？我想这正是我有点不同的地方。那从未发生过？不。我从来不怕让自己出丑。那太棒了。我总是觉得，没关系。
I fell down.
And maybe that was part of the athlete part too.
You know what I mean?
Like it was just like you're going to make mistakes.
You're going to fall.
You're going to do the...
Like I was ready.
I'm like, get back.
我摔倒了。也许这也是运动员属性的一部分。你知道我的意思吗？就像你会犯错。你会摔倒。你会做……我就像准备好了一样。我就想，再来。
Very scrappy.
Part of learning.
Part of success.
Yeah.
We'll be right back.
And now back to the show.
I was thinking about when you started and really started to sort of break through and I kind of want to get into what that was.
Because I'm not sure I really know what that thing was.
非常顽强。学习的一部分。成功的一部分。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。我一直在想你刚开始出道并真正开始崭露头角的那个时期，我其实挺想了解那是什么样的。因为我不太确定我是否真的了解那到底是什么。
I have questions about it.
Thank you, Sean.
this is not your time.
I'd like to reclaim my time.
Jennifer, I wonder if you know,
like the moment when you broke through
and you broke through on such a global level
in such a way that is very, very rare,
我对此有一些疑问。谢谢你，肖恩。现在不是你的时间。我想收回我的时间。詹妮弗，我想知道你是否清楚，比如你崭露头角的那个时刻，你以一种非常非常罕见的全球化水平崭露头角，
where everybody in the world knows who you are,
and just bear with me,
that you have the moment where you,
that kind of dawns on you,
the level of recognition and fame,
and then you as a person,
the gap of you catching up to that
and being okay with that on that kind of a level?
全世界每个人都知道你是谁，耐心听我说，你有没有那一刻，那种知名度和名气的程度开始向你袭来，然后作为个人的你，需要去追赶那种状态并在那种层面上接受它的过程？
Do you remember that time?
Was it a struggle kind of between you and it?
It was the worst.
It was, honestly, it was the worst.
It was, I had just done Selena.
Yeah.
And the movie came out, and I was still walking around, you know,
Hollywood, like going on auditions to it.
你还记得那个时期吗？你和它之间有过一番挣扎吗？那是糟透了。说实话，那真的是糟透了。那是我刚拍完《赛莲娜》（Selena）。是的。电影上映了，而我还在好莱坞四处走动，去参加各种试镜。
Like, it was still that time.
Yeah.
But it had just come out.
And I was walking down the street.
And for the first time, somebody was like,
hey hey
and they come running towards me and I thought
the motherfucker's gonna mug me
就还是那种时期。是的。但电影刚上映。我正走在街上。生平第一次，有人喊道：“嘿，嘿，”然后他们朝我跑过来，我当时心想这个混蛋要抢劫我
what the fuck is going on right now
like I got really nervous
and you know and I was just
you know like any woman in the world
you know we're threatened by
so many things like we're so scared
all the time in a weird way
and I was just walking
这他妈到底是怎么回事啊？我当时真的变得很紧张，你知道，就像世上任何一个女性一样，你知道，我们受到太多威胁，我们在某种奇怪的意义上总是那么害怕，我当时只是从我在洛杉矶的公寓
to the store from my apartment
in L.A. and
it was just so
jarring to me
And then I realized they were like, I saw you in whatever.
And I was like, oh.
Yeah.
I was like, I don't, but my thing was like, I don't know you.
走到商店，这对我来说太震撼了。然后我意识到他们是在说，我在什么地方看到过你，然后我就想，哦。是的。我就想，我不，但我的想法是，我不认识你。
Yeah.
Like, I don't know you.
Like, what are you doing?
Like, back up.
Don't touch me.
I was so scared.
And I remember it dawning on me.
I was like, oh, you're not anonymous anymore.
是的。就像，我不认识你。你这是在干嘛？离远点。别碰我。我当时太害怕了。我记得那一刻我突然明白，哦，你不再是匿名的了。
Right.
Your anonymity is gone.
Yeah.
And I don't, and I think in my mind, I thought, you can't get that back.
that's something that's lost forever
and I remember that's when I started having panic attacks
and I had oh it was terrible time for me
yeah can you talk about that when you were filming enough right
对。你的匿名性消失了。是的。而且我不，我想在我的心里，我当时想，你再也回不去了，那是永远失去的东西，我记得也就是在那时我开始经历恐慌发作，我有，哦，那对我来说是一段糟糕的时期。是的，你能谈谈拍《足够》（Enough）那会儿吗？
no that was another time
that was when I overworked myself
so bad when I didn't realize my limits
yeah but that I read about that
in preparation for this and that's fascinating to me
because I love medical stories
where you did you can you say what happened and why
yeah um so that was the kind of getting
不，那是另一个时期。那是我把自己累得太惨的时候，当时我没有意识到自己的极限。是的，我在为此做准备时读到过这个，这对我来说太迷人了，因为我喜欢医疗故事，你经历过，你能说说发生了什么以及为什么吗？
used to like fame and realizing your life had changed in a way that you couldn't control anymore.
Or go back.
You can't go back.
They're always going to know, somebody will always have seen Celine and somebody will always
and for whatever reason that really freaked me out.
And that took a minute.
But what you're talking about is when I was doing enough, I think I had done like four
movies in a row.
嗯，那就是那种习惯名气，并意识到你的生活以一种你无法控制的方式改变了的过程。或者回不去了。你回不去了。人们总是会知道，总会有人看过《赛莲娜》，而且无论出于什么原因，这真的把我吓坏了。这花了一点时间。但你刚才说的是我在拍《足够》的时候，我想我当时连续拍了大概四部电影。
And I had recorded my second album or something like that.
So the J-Lo album, which was really big.
Yeah, huge.
And what was like the J-Lo album.
And I was working, filming every day, as you guys know what that is, you know, all the hours.
And then I would go into the studio at night.
And then on the weekends, I, like, had junkets or video shoots or whatever.
And I remember not clocking that I had worked like 98 days in a row without taking a day off.
我还录制了我的第二张专辑之类的内容。也就是那张非常火的J-Lo专辑。是的，超级火。那张就是J-Lo专辑。我每天都在工作、拍电影，正如你们所知道的那样，就是所有的那些工时。然后我晚上会去录音室。然后在周末，我还要做宣传采访或拍MV之类的。我记得我完全没有意识到我已经连续工作了98天没有休息一天。
Right.
Because we went back and counted it because we're like, what happened?
And one day I'm sitting on the set of enough.
It's actually kind of thinking about it.
And I'm walking to the set every single time.
And every time I walk to the set, I start getting a little, like a little pitter-patter in my heart.
It's like rising.
And I go.
对，因为我们后来回去数了数，因为我们在想，到底发生了什么？有一天我坐在《足够》的片场。其实我当时正在想这件事。我每次都在走向片场。每当我走向片场时，我的心脏就开始有点像小鹿乱撞。它在加速。我就想。
And finally, it got to the point.
I was like, I really feel nervous.
And I had the little girl in enough.
And I was like, I'm sorry, sweetie.
I feel a little weird today.
I said a little tired or something.
And she was like, it's okay.
You're going to be all right.
最后，情况发展到了那个地步。我当时想，我真的觉得很紧张。片场里还有那个演《足够》的小女孩，我就说，对不起，亲爱的。我今天感觉有点怪。我说有点累什么的。她说，没关系。你会没事的。
You know, she's like going like this to my face.
But I wasn't all right.
And I went back to the trailer and I sat down and all of a sudden like I just couldn't see.
Like I was almost like I couldn't see clearly.
Like something just went over my eyes and I couldn't move.
And one of my girlfriends who was my friend since the second grade was my assistant.
And she was like, so she doesn't know, like, she doesn't know it.
She doesn't really know what she was doing too much.
你知道，她就像这样摸着我的脸。但我并不是没事。我回到拖车里坐下，突然之间，我什么也看不见了。就好像我视线开始模糊。有什么东西盖住了我的眼睛，我动不了了。我有一个从二年级起就是我朋友的闺蜜，当时她是我的助理。她当时说，她不知道，她其实不知道，她当时也不知道该怎么办。
But we love dugging it out together and figuring it out and being together.
And I said to her, Arlene, I can't move.
I can't see.
She goes, stop it, Jennifer, you're scaring me.
And I go, no, I really can't move.
I said, no, I can't move.
You should get somebody.
And she's like, stop, stop.
但我们喜欢一起挺过去，搞清楚状况并陪伴彼此。我对她说，阿琳，我动不了了。我看不见了。她说，别闹了，詹妮弗，你吓到我了。我说，不，我真的动不了了。我说，不，我动不了了。你得去找个人。她说，别闹了，别闹了。
I said, get B-O-B, my security.
security guard.
And she got me.
And I was like, I can't move and I can't see.
And I, like, I couldn't move.
I was just paralyzed.
Yeah, yeah.
And he picked me up and put me in the car.
我说，去找B-O-B，我的保安。然后她把他找来了。我当时说，我动不了也看不见。而且我，就像，我动不了了。我瘫痪了。是的，是的。他抱起我把我放进车里。
We went to the hospital.
Wow.
And it was crazy.
And I said to the doctor, I said, am I going crazy?
And he said, no, you're not crazy.
It's exhaustion.
Yeah, he's like, you're, you shut down.
I remember, I remember, speaking of Monster,
我们去了医院。哇。太疯狂了。我对医生说，我是不是疯了？他说，不，你没疯。这是精疲力竭。是的，他说，你，你宕机了。我记得，我记得，说到《怪兽岳母》，
I remember we were shooting a couple of days, like downtown somewhere,
and the level of attention,
I remember you having to drive to set,
and they had to put blinders on the thing for you to drive into,
and there were photographers on the roofs of the building across the street.
Yeah.
And I remember the...
And they had the base camp set up in this parking lot downtown,
我记得我们在市区某个地方拍了好几天，那种关注的程度，我记得你必须开车去片场，他们不得不给你的车装上遮挡板才能开进去，街对面大楼的屋顶上全都是摄影师。是的。我记得那个……他们把大本营设在市中心的一个停车场里，
and I remember these dudes randomly putting cameras under the fence
and just shooting like this, hoping to...
get somebody and I thought, oh my God.
Yeah.
That is so...
And by the way, there are a lot of people who go like, oh, well, that's the price you pay for fame
and all that kind of bullshit.
And you're like, oh, yeah.
我记得这些家伙随机把相机伸到围栏下面，就这样拍照，希望能拍到什么人，当时我想，哦，天哪。是的。太……顺便说一句，有很多人会说，哦，好吧，那是你为名气付出的代价，以及诸如此类的狗屁话。然后你会觉得，哦，是的。
That's pretty rough, man.
Like, you don't have a second.
Yeah, it can be really tricky.
And you learn to kind of, like, live a certain way.
Like, I don't go out all that much, you know?
And I, I...
To this day?
No where I can go.
这挺艰难的，老兄。就像你连一秒钟都没有。是的，这真的很棘手。你会学会以某种方式生活。比如，我不怎么出门，你知道吗？而且，我……直到今天都不出？不知道能去哪儿。
Yeah, to this day.
And I have my, like, very small group of friends and they come over.
or we do things or we go on trips
but even when we go on trips
it's very curated
and you have to learn
because it's just
it's part of it.
是的，直到今天。我有着非常小的朋友圈，他们会来我家，或者我们一起做点什么，或者我们去旅行。但即使我们去旅行，行程也是精心策划的，你必须去适应，因为这只是生活的一部分。
Jason calls photographers
he lets them know
they have his schedule
they have access to his ICAL
they never show
and they never show
what about
now that sort of
杰森会给摄影师打电话，让他们知道他的日程安排，他们能看他的苹果日历，但他们从来不出现，也从不露面。那现在呢？既然医用口罩在公共场合如此被接受、如此普遍，你曾经享受过那种找到安宁的程度吗？
surgical masks are so sort of like
accepted in public
and so commonplace now
do you ever enjoy that level
of you know
sort of finding animals?
I feel like people always know it's me and I feel stupid.
Like if I put on a hat like too long, they're like, it's like, is that J-Lo?
我觉得人们总是知道那就是我，而且我觉得自己很蠢。如果我把帽子戴得太低，他们就会说，那就像是，那是J-Lo吗？
Jay-Lo?
You know what I mean?
It's like stupid.
I put a mask on.
They'll even recognize my voice sometimes if I'm not just talking in a store.
Like I'll see people creep around the aisle like they heard me talking.
And I'm like, hi.
Did your friends call you J-Lo when you were a kid growing up?
杰·洛？你知道我的意思吗？这太蠢了。我戴上口罩。如果我在商店里说话，他们甚至有时候能认出我的声音。我看到人们在过道里鬼鬼祟祟地走动，好像他们听到我在说话。我就想，嗨。你小时候朋友们叫你J-Lo吗？
No.
No, not at all.
Not at all.
That was something that I was.
at Heavy D. I don't know if you guys remember.
Oh, yeah, because he was a rapper back in the day.
Back in the day. And we all, all the Sony artists, there was a place called the hit factory
here in New York. And all of us recorded there. A lot of people recorded there. It was a big
不。没有，完全没有。那是……Heavy D叫的。我不知道你们记不记得。哦，对，因为他当年是个说唱歌手。当年。我们所有，所有的索尼艺人，在纽约有个地方叫“热门工厂”（Hit Factory）。我们所有人都在那儿录音。很多人都在那儿录音。那是一个很大的
studio. And we'd always, people would always come in and out, you know, to other people's studios.
And I met Heavy at that time. And he was, he just always used to call me Jenny Lowe.
He's like, J. Lo! Jay Lo! Jenny Lowe. And I was like, I think, I think,
I'm going to call my next album J-Lo.
I love that.
That's so cool.
Yeah, and that's kind of how it happened.
It was really very simple.
录音室。我们总是，人们总是进进出出，去彼此的录音室。我在那个时候遇到了Heavy。他总是叫我Jenny Lo。他会喊：J-Lo！J-Lo！Jenny Lo。我就想，我想，我要把我的下一张专辑叫作《J-Lo》。我喜欢这样。太酷了。是的，事情就是这样发生的。真的很简单。
It just stuck.
When did Jenny from the block come?
I was going to get to Jenny from the block, yeah.
It was the next album.
So J-Lo was my second album.
The first album was on the sixth.
And my third album was,
This Is Me Then.
就这么定下来了。“街区女孩珍妮”是什么时候出现的？我本来就要说到“街区女孩珍妮”，是的。那是下一张专辑。所以J-Lo是我的第二专辑。第一专辑是第六感。第三专辑是，那就是我。
And that had Jenny from the Block on it.
Do you know you spawned how many people in the world
probably refer to their friends,
Jennifer, as Jenny from the block.
Like, we have a friend.
Oh, my God.
Right?
Yeah, you do come across it.
那张专辑里有《街区女孩珍妮》。你知道吗，世界上大概有多少人把他们的朋友（名字叫詹妮弗的）叫做“街区女孩珍妮”。比如，我们有个朋友。噢，天哪。对吧？是啊，你确实经常遇到这种情况。
But also they all do their names.
Oh, my, they people call me Ado.
Yeah, right, right, right.
Like, they put their name together and stuff like that.
Jason would be J-bah.
Yeah, you'd be J-B, J-B.
J-B.
And you're C-Hah.
但他们也会把名字缩写。噢，天哪，人们叫我阿多。对，对，对，对。就像，他们把名字连在一起之类的。杰森就是J-巴。对，你就是J-B，J-B。J-B。而你是C-哈。
Some C-Hah.
Say-ha.
It doesn't work.
But getting back to the, the,
有些C-哈。塞-哈。塞-哈。行不通。行不通。行不通。行不通。但回到那个，那个，
when you were first starting,
because I think it's fascinating
that you went from the time frame
of in living color,
which was, you know,
its own story,
which we could probably talk about forever,
but in living color to Money Train,
你刚开始的时候，因为我觉得很有意思，你从《生动色彩》那个时期走过来，你知道，那有它自己的故事，我们可能可以永远谈下去，但从《生动色彩》到《洛杉矶大劫案》，
to Selena,
at that time,
you really had to prove yourself as an actress,
and you probably worked hard to do that, right?
What did that period feel like
when you look back on it where you're like,
wait, how do I transit,
how do I get people to take me seriously
再到《瑟琳娜》，在那个时候，你真的必须证明自己是一名演员，你可能为此付出了很多努力，对吧？当你回首那段时期，你感觉如何，当时你是不是在想，等等，我该如何转型，我该如何让人们认真对待我，
from dancing on in living color to,
to being an actress.
Well, it's funny.
My very first movie was a movie called My Family, Me Familia, which Greg Nava did.
And it had Edward James Olmos in it.
That was the very first time I worked with him.
And I played the young matriarch in the movie.
And right from that moment, I think people seeing that little piece of tape, that really
从在《生动色彩》里跳舞到，到成为一名演员。嗯，这很有趣。我的第一部电影是一部叫《我的家庭，我的家族》的电影，格雷格·纳瓦导演的。里面有爱德华·詹姆斯·奥莫斯。那是我第一次跟他合作。我在电影里扮演年轻的家族女家长。从那一刻起，我觉得人们看到那一小段录像，真的
helped make the transition.
Because it was a great little role.
And I had to cross the river from Mexico.
into the thing and I'm like swimming and so I'm like I'm actiony and I'm crying with the baby and I'm like it was like a great little juicy it was a small role but it was juicy and with that piece of tape people were like oh she can act she's an actress and I was and I had worked on it before I did my first movie I studied it acting all through a and living color really bought me out to Los Angeles and that's when I started like taking classes all the time and reading all the books and doing all the things I love you did and then you did God I
remember this movie holds up i love it so much you're so great in out of sight oh my god yeah you're so
that movie is so good so so so so so you're so good in that it's such a great movie you know
really is you really dragged cloney along you know because no you did launched you launched something
you did you made cluny look good and i don't care if he hears this you made it look good and that
对完成转型很有帮助。因为那是个很棒的小角色。我得从墨西哥渡河，然后到了那边，我在游泳，所以我像是在拍动作戏，我抱着婴儿在哭，就像是个很棒的、很有发挥空间的角色，戏份虽然不多但很出彩，凭借那段录像，人们觉得“哦，她会演戏，她是个演员”，而我确实也是，在我拍第一部电影之前我就下过功夫，我在《生动色彩》期间一直在学习表演，这真的把我带到了洛杉矶，从那时起我开始一直上表演课，读所有的书，做所有我热爱的事，你做到了，然后你拍了，天哪，我记得这部电影真的很经典，我太喜欢了，你在《战略高手》里表现太棒了，噢，天哪，是的，你在那部电影里太棒了，那部电影太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，你在里面太棒了，真的是一部好电影，你知道的，真的是，你把克鲁尼都带飞了，你知道的，因为，不，你做到了，你开启了某种东西，你做到了，你让克鲁尼看起来很帅，我才不管他听不听得到，你让他看起来很帅，而且还有，
soda bird character and sodaberg too yeah yeah it's even too you really helped those guys yeah i really helped
No, but talk about that movie, if you will, just a little bit,
because that was like a real, that movie, like, really went like,
she knows what she's doing.
Yeah.
I mean, you already were, but.
Yeah, I was excited.
Listen, I got really lucky in the beginning of my career to work with, like,
索德伯格那个角色，还有索德伯格本人，对，对，你们俩配合得真好，你真的帮了那些家伙，我真的帮了，不，如果你愿意的话，稍微聊聊那部电影，因为那是部真正的好电影，那部电影，让人觉得，她知道自己在做什么。是啊。我的意思是，你本来就是，但是。是的，我很兴奋。听着，我职业生涯的初期真的很幸运，能跟一些非常优秀的导演合作，
some really great directors, Steven Soderberg, Oliver Stone, Francis Ford Coppola.
Like, I was, like, I worked with Robin Williams.
Like, there was, it was a really beautiful, beautiful beginning to an acting career for me,
for sure.
Yeah, and working on Out of Sight, it was funny.
The thing I remember the most about Out of Sight was one of the things is Steve's on,
because we had like one of the most epic nights ever singing musical theater.
I think I was singing to him and telling him I was going to be a singer, and he was like,
史蒂芬·索德伯格、奥利弗·斯通、弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉。就像，我，就像，我和罗宾·威廉姆斯合作过。我的演艺生涯有一个非常美丽、非常美好的开端，肯定的。是的，拍《战略高手》时，挺有趣的。我对《战略高手》印象最深的一件事是史蒂夫在，因为我们有过最史诗般的夜晚之一，一起唱音乐剧。我想我当时在给他唱歌，告诉他我要当歌手，然后他说，
you're right.
I was like, I am.
I'm working on my album right now.
Like, I was so young and kind of like goofy and whatever.
But I also remember like.
the auditioning process for that.
And going, I remember the last, like, I read for Stephen, and he was like, I think I like
these talking to George.
你说得对。我说，对啊。我正在做我的专辑呢。我当时太年轻了，有点傻里傻气的，随便吧。但我也记得那个试镜过程。我去，我记得最后一次，我去给史蒂芬试镜，他说，我觉得我喜欢，在和乔治交谈时，
Like, I like this girl, Jennifer Lopez to play this role.
And he was like, okay, and they had me go do like a chemistry read.
And I had to drive to George's house.
And I remember getting there and there was a pig in the front yard.
I was like, this is some real Hollywood shit.
This is some weird stuff.
And Richard Kine, collecting the mail.
He had his pig, and we were there.
就像，我喜欢这个女孩，詹妮弗·洛佩兹来演这个角色。然后他说，好吧，他们让我去做个化学反应测试。我得开车去乔治家。我记得到了那里，前院里竟然有一头猪。我当时想，这可真够好莱坞的。这太诡异了。还有理查·肯恩，在收信。他带着他的猪，我们就在那儿。
And we, you know, we read like on the couch together,
literal casting couch.
And we were just had this chemistry that really worked.
And Stephen just loved it.
And I got the role.
And I was so happy because it was a really great role as well.
Did you get it there in the room?
Yeah, I think, yeah, by the time I got home,
然后我们，你知道的，就一起在沙发上试读，字面意义上的“试镜沙发”。我们之间那种化学反应真的很契合。史蒂芬非常喜欢。我就拿到了这个角色。我太开心了，因为这也是个非常棒的角色。你当时在房间里就拿到了吗？对，我想，是的，等我回到
home they had called my agent and said that you know they wanted me oh that's great how do you with with
with with so much ability um across um you know mediums how and and and anything that you basically
declare you're going to do it's going to find financing and it's going to find an audience how do you
decide what to do if if if if anything is a viable direction like i mean you could you could start a musical
tomorrow or you could do another album or you could you could finance you could start a movie you could
you could act in that movie directed that movie you could do it you could do it you could start like a
cupcake store down the street that would be come up i do have i do have cookie dough that i would think
i call j dough there you go oh for real that is the best chocolate cookies in the world and one day i'm going
家，他们就已经打电话给我经纪人说他们想要我了。噢，太棒了。你拥有如此强大的能力，跨越了这么多领域，任何你宣称要去做的事情，都能找到资金，找到观众，你究竟是如何决定该做什么的，如果，如果，如果任何方向都是可行的——比如，你可以明天就开启一个音乐剧，或者你可以再做一张专辑，或者你可以，你可以出资，你可以开拍一部电影，你可以在那部电影里演戏，导演那部电影，你可以做到，你可以做到，你可以在街角开一家纸杯蛋糕店，那会成为，我确实有，我确实有饼干面团，我觉得我叫它J面团。给你，噢，真的吗，那是世界上最好吃的巧克力曲奇，有一天我要
i'm going to i'm going to i'm going to make this i'm going to share it with the world because you're so
but you don't sell you don't sell it yet no no that's a mistake this is this is
We can announce it today.
Leave the money on the table.
This is a big J-Dow.
I want it.
We love Chuck.
Chip Cook.
我要，我要，我要把它做出来，我要把它分享给全世界，因为你太，但你现在还没开始卖，不，不，那是错的，这是，我们可以今天就宣布。把钱留在桌面上。这是一个巨大的J面团。我想要它。我们爱巧克力曲奇。
Truly, so how do you decide where to point your energy and your assets?
You know, it's funny.
You ask that question because I don't think, I think one of the things about my career and sometimes, you know, there's any long career, there's ups and downs.
You swing for the fences and you, you know, fail.
And then there's times when it's just like, you know, you just hit it out of the park.
And right now, I think I just didn't ever realize that I had that kind of power.
I always felt, again, like the scrappy one kind of trying to make it.
And erring on the side of humility and not assuming something till you're sure.
真的，那你究竟是如何决定把你的精力和资产投向哪里的？你知道，这很有趣。你问这个问题，因为我不认为，我觉得我的职业生涯的特点之一，有时候，你知道，任何漫长的职业生涯都有起起落落。你全力以赴，然后，你知道，失败了。然后也有时候，就像，你知道，你直接全垒打。而现在，我觉得我以前从没意识到自己拥有那种力量。我总是觉得自己，再次强调，就像个苦苦挣扎、试图成功的人。并且偏向于谦逊，在确信之前不要妄下定论。
I think that's a healthy place to be.
And it did serve me in certain ways.
But in other ways, I always felt like whatever I got was good enough instead of going, wait a minute.
Is this the right thing to do right now?
Or is that the right?
It was just kind of like work, work, work, work, work, work.
I'm working, I'm working, I'm working.
And I think it wasn't just now as I'm, my kids are about to leave to college in about a few months.
我觉得这是一个健康的处境。它在某些方面确实对我有帮助。但在另我方面，我总是觉得无论我得到什么都足够好了，而不是去想，等一下。现在做这个是正确的选择吗？或者那个才是对的？当时就只是像工作、工作、工作、工作、工作、工作。我在工作，我在工作，我在工作。我想直到现在，随着我的，我的孩子们在几个月后就要去上大学了。
They're both 18.
Don't make me cry, okay.
Wow.
I'm with you.
Yeah, and they're twins.
So they're both leaving at the same time.
It's just going to be me by myself.
And I'm looking at like what I really want to do.
他们都18岁了。别把我弄哭，好吗。哇。我陪着你。是的，而且他们是双胞胎。所以他们俩同时离家。那就只剩我一个人了。我在思考我真正想做的是什么。
And for the first time in my life, I've really taken more control.
of exactly what you're saying.
Like, what do you really want to do?
Like, do you want to direct?
Do you want to do musicals?
What have you not done that really feels fulfilling to you?
Because I actually have realized that I do have that.
That I have earned that over these years.
这是我生命中第一次，我真正掌握了更多主动权，完全就像你说的。比如，你到底想做什么？比如，你想当导演吗？你想做音乐剧吗？还有什么事是你没做过，但对你来说真正有成就感的？因为我实际上意识到，我确实拥有那种能力。这些年来我配得上这一切。
And I should be very, I want to be very intentional about what I do over these next four or five years.
You can take agency over your own life.
Yeah.
And also, like, give myself up.
a pat on the back, which I never did.
I never do, and I never did.
You should.
Where I go, you know what?
而且我应该非常，我想要非常刻意地安排我在接下来这四五年里要做的事情。你可以掌控你自己的生活。是的。而且，还要给自己拍拍肩膀鼓励一下，我从来没有这么做过。我从来不，我也从没做过。你应该这样。每当我心想，你知道吗？
You created this.
That little girl would like, I always say this with like holes in her shoes in the Bronx.
You know what I mean?
I mean, I wear my sneakers down where this part of my foot was out all the time.
I'm sure that's going to be a mean.
If I ask you right now, what do you really love and value most in your life?
I'm sure that you would say your kids.
But if I narrowed that to what your career represents for you,
这一切都是你创造的。那个小女孩，我总是这样形容，在布朗克斯穿着鞋子破了个洞的小女孩。你知道我的意思吗？我的运动鞋磨损得脚趾那部分总是露在外面。我敢确定这会变成一个表情包。如果我现在问你，你一生中最真正热爱和珍视的是什么？我确信你会说是你的孩子们。但如果我把范围缩小到你的职业生涯对你意味着什么，
what is it just sort of in a pursuit of like trying to find an answer for what you would want to do next or your next chapter to be
what is it that you enjoy the most that you that your career has provided you is it is it respect is it
endless possibility yeah i think it's the that i have opened up an avenue for myself where there's an endless
possibility and i can really create a new dream right now for myself yeah for sure
And I just moved into a new house.
Like, everything in my life has changed over the past couple of years.
I moved into a new house.
What happened?
为了寻找关于你接下来想做什么或人生的下一个篇章的答案，你从职业生涯中获得的最大乐趣是什么？是尊重，还是无限的可能？对，我认为是我为自己开辟了一条充满无限可能的道路，我现在真的可以为自己创造一个新的梦想了，对，确实如此。我刚刚搬进了一个新家。过去几年里，我生活中的一切都变了。我搬进了新家。怎么回事？
I'm kidding.
Oh, that's for another time.
It's a different podcast.
That's a different.
Right, right.
Guys, keep rolling.
开玩笑的。开玩笑的。噢，那是以后的话题了。那是另一个播客。那是另一个。对，对。伙计们，继续录。伙计们，继续录。
Keep rolling.
You come over, we have a glass of wine.
And you come to the new house and it's amazing.
And I, like, built my little corner of the world dream house.
I've got my kids some horses.
We have stables.
Oh, that's great.
Like, I was like, please come home.
继续录。你过来，我们喝一杯酒。你来到新家，它棒极了。我，就像，建造了我梦想中的世界的小角落。我给我的孩子们弄了些马。我们有马厩。噢，太棒了。就像，我当时说，请回家吧。
Please come back home to your horses.
There's horses here.
And just really thinking about, like, with all this change, it's actually been a very emotional time for me where, yes, I'm crying because they're leaving.
But I'm also, like, staring down, like, what is my life now?
The past 20 years, it's been one thing.
the past five years has been a tumult, you know,
and then the last two years has been kind of the healing process from that tumult
where I really got to know myself.
请回你的马这里来吧。这里有马。我真的在思考，伴随着所有的这些改变，这对我来说其实是一个非常情绪化的时期，是的，我会因为他们要离开而哭泣。但我也在直面，我现在的生活是什么样的？过去的20年里，生活是某一类样子的。过去的五年是一场动荡，你知道的，然后最近两年则是从那场动荡中恢复的过程，在这个过程中我真正认识了自己。
And the person I am today is so different than the person I was even two years ago.
It's crazy.
And now I can really look at my life, appreciate it for what it is,
and what I've created for myself, and be really happy.
and both my kids, like, got into all their colleges
and they both got scholarships
and they're going where they want to go.
And it's just, I was like, you did that shit all by yourself.
今天的我和甚至两年前的我截然不同。这太疯狂了。现在我可以真正审视我的生活，欣赏它本来的样子，以及我为自己创造的一切，并感到由衷的快乐。而且我的两个孩子，都考上了他们想去的大学，他们都拿到了奖学金，去他们想去的地方。我就觉得，这一切都是你凭一己之力做到的。
That's great.
Like, you had very little help, you know?
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
I was just going to say, I think it's awesome
that you, the way that you talk about it
and you seem so sort of clear-headed and calm,
knowing we sort of joke about it
太棒了。就像，你几乎没得到什么帮助，你知道吗？我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。我正想说，我觉得太棒了，你谈论这些的方式，你看上去如此清醒和冷静，尽管我们开玩笑说，
about how much people perceive or think that they know about your life
and what you've gone through and all that kind of stuff.
And you have to kind of put that in a weird place
because people have this sort of thing that they think,
but you have to actually go through it.
And like you said, when you started,
like you're just a human being and people forget that.
You know what I mean?
人们对你的生活以及你经历过的事情有多少感知或自以为是的了解，诸如此类。你不得不把这些放在一个奇怪的位置，因为人们有这种成见，但你必须亲身去经历它。就像你说的，当你刚开始时，你只是个普通人，而人们却忘记了这一点。你知道我的意思吗？
It's so crazy to me because we don't really understand other people's experiences
unless we walk in their shoes.
Right.
And there's also, I think, I think, I don't mean to catch off, really, but I do think, you know, we're all, we're all aware of and some of us are friends with some people that have like this enormous level of celebrity and exposure that actually enables the ability for, enables them to stay exactly who that is for kind of as long as they want.
In other words, there's this, there's this real permissive culture around celebrity and you don't kind of have to be the best.
best part of you and you don't have to grow like you know what you just said Jennifer that you know
the past two years has been about the healing and that you're you're you're you're you're so different
now than you were even two years ago five years ago do you do you recognize that that's that that can be
这对我来说太疯狂了，因为除非我们亲身体验过别人的鞋子，否则我们无法真正理解别人的经历。对。而且还有，我认为，我认为——我不是故意打断你，瑞莉——但我确实认为，你知道，我们都知道，我们当中有些人甚至和某些拥有巨大名气和曝光度的人是朋友，这种名气实际上赋予了他们一种能力，让他们能够想保持现在的样子多久就多久。换句话说，围绕着名气有一种真正的纵容文化，你不需要展现出最好的自己，你也不需要成长——你知道你刚才说的，詹妮弗，过去两年一直是关于疗愈的，你现在的你和两年前甚至五年前的你大不相同——你，你，你是否意识到，对于你这个地位的人来说，这可以算是一个真正的成就？我觉得这是一个很棒的“好样的”，你显然付出了时间和精力、自我反思，
a real accomplishment for somebody in your position like I think that's a real great adder boy that
you've clearly put in time and work and self-reflection and yeah could have just kind of just
kept eating the junk food of of the permissive culture around you
and just kind of lean back.
But it sounds like you're leaning into
who am I going to be for this next chapter?
Yeah.
And what have I learned, et cetera, et cetera.
本来大可以继续沉溺于围绕着你的这种纵容文化的“垃圾食品”中，然后顺其自然。但听起来你正在倾注心力去思考：我要成为下一个篇章中的什么样的人？是的。以及我学到了什么，等等，等等。
100%.
I, again, there's been different times
where I felt like whether people outside knew it or not
where I feel like my life blew up in my own face.
And it was because of the choices I made,
but also because of the fact that I had things
that needed to change about my sense.
that I didn't understand or recognize that was attracting certain things and attracting a certain
100%是的。再次重申，有好几次，不管外面的人知不知道，我都觉得自己的人生彻底崩盘了。这是因为我做出的选择，也是因为我身上有些事情需要改变，那些我当时并不理解或没有意识到、却在吸引着某些特定事物和某种
type of, you know, experience into my life. And I really needed, I fight, honestly, it's that thing
where, and you can go either way, you're right, it is a choice. So I want to give myself that credit
too, but there comes a point where it's all so puzzling and wrong where you have to sit there,
And after my last divorce, I just sat there.
And I was like, I canceled my Torah and I sat there.
And I was just like, you need to fucking figure yourself out.
What is going on with you?
Forget about everybody else.
特定经历进入我生活的东西。我真的需要，老实说，就是那种情况，你可以走向任何一条路，你说得对，这是一个选择。所以我也想给自己这份肯定，但当事情变得如此令人困惑和错误时，你不得不坐在那里，在我最后一次离婚后，我就坐在那里。我取消了巡演，坐在那里。我当时想：你必须把自己的烂摊子收拾好。你到底怎么了？别管其他人了。
There's nobody to blame here except yourself in a certain way.
Not that people don't behave in a way that's not great.
But what are you doing?
What do you have going on?
And that was a turning point for me.
and that was a couple of years ago now.
I had the same thing about two, three years ago.
Maybe I've told you guys this in private before,
除了你自己，在某种程度上这里没有人可怪的。并不是说别人的行为就无可挑剔。但你自己在做什么呢？你身上到底发生了什么？那对我来说是一个转折点。那已经是几年前的事了。大约两三年我也经历过同样的事。也许我以前私下里跟你们说过这个，
but I had a moment before I got into real therapy a couple of years ago
where one day I was making coffee in the morning
and I swear to God, and I went, I remember distinctly what was happening.
Oat milk.
Not the date.
And I remember, and I went, I said out loud to myself, it's you.
Right?
但在几年前我真正开始做心理治疗之前，我有过这样一个时刻：有一天早上我在做咖啡，我发誓对上帝，我当时脑子里在想，我清楚地记得当时正在发生什么。燕麦奶。不是椰枣。燕麦奶。我记得，我当时自言自语说出来：原来是你。对吧？
And I had this real, I was like, oh, my God, I need to do some work.
I go, it's me.
But by the way, everybody needs to do that at some point in your life.
And by the way, everybody goes through this.
I mean, it's all sort of relative.
It's part of being human, right?
Exactly.
We all have things to blow up.
我当时有这种真切的感悟，我说：天哪，我得做点心理建设了。我说：是我。顺便说一句，每个人在人生的某个阶段都需要经历这个。而且顺便说一句，每个人都会经历这些。我的意思是，这其实都大同小异。这是身为人类的一部分，对吧？没错。我们每个人都有生活崩塌的时候。
We get these parents.
They do the best they can or they do as much as they can.
They form certain parts about ourselves.
And then our journey is kind of the undoing and the healing of those things,
of the patterns that that created.
And so in doing and looking at those patterns, I was able to kind of like go back to that little girl and really look at her and go, that little seven-year-old girl, like I said, with the ripped nightgown, like I can see her right now with it.
Like my hair was like up to here and it was about the same color.
And you know what I mean?
我们都有父母。他们尽力做到最好，或者他们尽其所能。他们塑造了我们身上的某些部分。然后我们的旅程就是去解构和疗愈那些东西，疗愈那些模式所创造的东西。因此，在解构和审视这些模式时，我得以回到那个小女孩身边，真正地看着她，心想：那个七岁的小女孩，就像我说的，穿着破睡裙——我甚至能清晰地看到她现在的样子。我的头发当时梳得这么高，颜色也差不多。你知道我的意思吗？
30 feet walking around barefoot all the fucking time.
And I was like, you, you, you, yeah, just thanks.
She's bad.
Still nothing's changed.
Still, Jenny from the block.
And just kind of like going, you did this.
Yeah, yeah.
You did all this.
赤脚在外面跑来跑去，整天光着脚。我当时想：你，你，你，是的，谢谢。她很糟糕。但一切依然没有改变。依然是那个街区女孩珍妮。然后就觉得：这一切都是你干的。对，对。这一切都是你干的。
Yeah.
Give yourself a little fucking something, like a little love.
Right.
Stop looking for love and other things.
Yeah.
And give it to yourself.
Yeah, there's so much to love in you.
Yeah, yeah.
对。给自己一点该死的奖励，比如一点爱。对。别再去别的地方寻找爱了。是的。把它留给自己。是的，你身上有那么多值得爱的地方。对，对。
Yeah.
And you don't see it because you're in this business and everybody's telling you're bad at this
and you're bad at that and they're scrutinizing and criticizing.
Yeah.
personal, your professional life and you're not doing this enough or you didn't choose that right
movie or that song didn't do as good as last one and you're like, and it plays on you. It plays on
those places that were reinforced when you were younger of like whatever it is the impressions
that were made on you because of the way you were loved or cared for in different ways. And it's
是的。而你看不到，因为你身处这个行业，每个人都在告诉你“你这不行，那不行”，他们在审视和批判。是的。你的个人生活，你的职业生活，你做得还不够，你没选对电影，或者那首歌不如上一首火，你会觉得，这会影响到你。它会触及你内心深处那些在你年轻时被不断强化的创伤，无论那是什么——那些因为你曾经被以不同方式去爱或关心而留下的印记。这
just, it's also intertwined. And I find it very interesting and I love it because
I really do believe people are capable of change because I've experienced it.
Same.
And a lot of that fuel for change comes from that self-love,
but that self-love is often so hard for all of us to kind of recognize and utilize
because it's hard to see because we're living with ourselves every day.
You know, you kind of get used to some of the things that you really should be taking a second
to be pleased with about yourself.
一切都是盘根错节的。我觉得这非常有趣，我也很喜欢，因为我真的相信人类是有能力改变的，因为我亲身经历过。我也是。而这种改变的很大一部分动力来自于自爱，但这种自爱对我们所有人来说往往很难去认知和利用，因为它很难被看到，因为我们每天都和自己生活在一起。你知道，你往往会习惯于某些你本该花时间为自己感到高兴的事情。
It's like you can't see.
your own hair grow, right?
Like, you see, you see, you see every day.
I also think people don't understand what it is to love yourself.
Like, to understand, to, whatever you want.
And I think having kids for me changed a lot of that because I realize, whatever I want to give
them, like, why wouldn't I give that to myself?
Right.
这就好像你看不见自己的头发在生长，对吧？你看不到，你每天都看着自己。我也觉得人们并不真正懂得什么是爱自己。比如去理解，无论你想要什么。我觉得对我来说，拥有孩子改变了许多这方面的看法，因为我意识到，无论我想给他们什么——我为什么不把那些也给自己呢？对。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why don't I appreciate those things about it?
Why don't I, you know, if you want respect from people, you have to respect yourself.
Those are actions, right?
Like, those are real tangible things.
And being my.
sister said to me once, Linda, who I think is so smart, and she was like, when are you going to be
your own keeper? You keep everybody else. You take care of mom. You take care of me. You take care of the
对，对，对。我为什么不欣赏自己身上的那些特质呢？为什么不，你知道的，如果你想得到别人的尊重，你必须先尊重自己。这些都是行动，对吧？这些都是真实有形的东西。有一次我姐姐琳达对我说——我觉得她特别聪明——她说：“你什么时候能成为你自己的守护者？你照顾所有人。你照顾妈妈。你照顾我。你照顾
kids. You take care of everybody who works for you. You take care. When are you going to be your
own keeper? And I was just like, yeah, and these are all little pieces. I feel like the journey is
like pieces, pieces, little puzzle pieces that you fit in little as you like sit there with
the oat milk and go, it's me.
Yeah.
This fucking thing that just happened, me.
Right, right.
And you know, you mentioned the kids.
孩子们。你照顾所有为你工作的人。你照顾所有人。你什么时候才能照顾好你自己？”我当时就想：是的，这些都是零碎的片段。我觉得人生之旅就像是一块块拼图，当你坐在那里喝着燕麦奶时，把它们拼起来，然后心想：就是我。对。刚刚发生的这堆破事，全是我干的。对，对。你知道，你提到了孩子们。
I sort of realized also that, like, that act of, the way that we love our kids, for me
anyway, my experience is that act of being loving to them allows, the reason it feels so good
is because you're generating that and then you get it back.
And it's when you close off and you don't act in a loving way pushing it.
I find the more I push out, the more it comes back.
And so, like, with my kids,
That's why it feels so good
because you're creating that
我也意识到，这种行为——我们爱孩子的方式，对我和我的经历来说——那种充满爱意的行为之所以感觉这么好，是因为你在散发这种爱，然后你又得到了回馈。而当你封闭自己，没有以充满爱意的方式去付出时。我发现你付出的越多，收获的也就越多。所以，对我的孩子们来说，
as opposed to kind of rolling up the window on it.
Do you know what I mean?
Absolutely.
No, I agree.
And the kids are a great learner,
but relationships are great, you know,
kind of learning grounds as well
where you really get to face yourself.
这就是为什么感觉这么好，因为你在创造这种爱，而不是把心门紧闭。你知道我的意思吗？当然。不，我同意。孩子们是很好的学习对象，但人际关系同样也是很好的学习园地，在其中你真正能够直面自我。
And if you get lucky enough to be with somebody
who actually really cares and loves about you
in the right way,
there's a lot you can learn from each other,
even if things don't work out.
You know what I mean?
But Jason, I'm sorry I cut you off.
I was just like had to get that thought out before I was.
如果你足够幸运，能和一个真正关心你、用正确的方式爱着你的人在一起，你们可以从彼此身上学到很多东西，即使事情最后没有结果。你知道我的意思吗？不过，杰森，对不起，我打断你了。我只是必须把那个想法说出来，否则。
No, no, I was kind of done.
I was just saying it's a dumb metaphor or analogy,
not being able to recognize your own hair growing
because we see ourselves in the mirror every single day,
but if you don't see somebody for a few weeks ago,
oh, your hair's gotten long.
Your hair's got a beard.
You can't really see the things inside of you
不，不，我差不多说完了。我只是在说，这其实是个很蠢的比喻或类比，说什么“察觉不到自己头发在生长”，因为我们每天都在镜子里看到自己，但如果你几周没见某个人，你会说：“哦，你头发变长了。你留胡子了。”你其实看不清自己内心深处那些
that you probably should be, you've got the greatest hair of all time.
I was trying to back into a compliment.
I know. Jason's got the greatest hair.
Do you really
fucking do.
It's unbelievable.
You know what?
Jennifer, you want to know something?
你应该意识到的东西——你拥有史上最棒的头发。我这是在拐弯抹角地夸人呢。我知道。杰森的头发太棒了。你TMD真的是。太不可思议了。你知道吗？詹妮弗，你想知道一件事吗？
He hasn't put a comb or a brush in it since he was 11.
That's a new story.
Stop!
And he doesn't color it.
He doesn't color it.
Also true.
He's so handsome.
Guys.
他从11岁起就没用过梳子或刷子梳过头。这又是个新故事。住手！而且他从来不染发。他从来不染发。这也是真的。他太帅了。伙计们。
You know, I mentioned it before, Jen, it's like, you know, the...
Well, maybe I didn't mention it.
I think mentioned in the intro where you left home when you were really young and you slept in a
dance studio or something as a...
I did.
As a girl.
I have done the crazy.
things. I know, but don't you look back at that with everything we're talking about now
你知道，我之前提到了，詹恩，就像，你知道，……好吧，也许我没提到。我想在开场白里提过，你很小的时候就离家出走，作为一个……我确实这么做过。作为一个女孩，睡在舞蹈工作室的地上或类似的地方。我做过那些疯狂的
and giving yourself and loving yourself, looking at that and going, well, I was sleeping on the
floor of a studio on my own, not living at home. And look what I've done. Like, it's just mind-blowing.
It's crazy because my mom and dad, like, I was about to start college or I had just done a
semester of college. And I was just like, I had a dream that I'm going to be in show business.
And they were like, we lived in the Bronx.
They were like, this crazy bitch.
And I was just like, no, dad.
And my mom was like, you're not dropping out of college.
事情。我知道，但结合我们现在谈论的一切——给予自己并爱自己——回首过去，看着那段经历，心想，好吧，我当时一个人睡在工作室的地上，没有住在家里。看看我都做了些什么。这简直让人匪夷所思。太疯狂了，因为我爸爸妈妈，当时我正准备上大学，或者刚读完一个学期的大学。我当时就想：我有梦想，我要去娱乐圈发展。他们住在布朗克斯。他们觉得：这个疯女人。我当时说：不，爸爸。我妈妈说：你绝对不能从大学辍学。
You are crazy.
You know how much we do this so you can go to college and da-da-da-da.
And my dad was like, did you have a dream?
Really?
I said, Daddy, I did.
I really did.
No, da-da.
Anyway, the next few months was tumultuous.
你简直疯了。你知道我们为了让你上大学付出了多少心血，巴拉巴拉巴拉。我爸爸说：你真的有梦想吗？真的吗？我说：爸爸，我有的。我真的有。不，巴拉巴拉。不管怎样，接下来的几个月充满了动荡。
And I wound up leaving the house.
And I kept skipping.
I stopped going to class.
college and I was going to the dance studio and literally taking class all day.
I just so fallen in love with it.
I was, yeah, I wanted to be a lawyer.
I worked in a law office for a few years during high school and I was like really good
with numbers and taxes and things like that.
我最后还是离家出走了。我开始疯狂旷课。我不去上大学了，而是去舞蹈工作室，字面意义上整天上课。我深深地爱上了它。我本来，是的，我想当律师。我在高中时在律所工作过几年，我对数字、税务之类的事情真的很擅长。
I don't know.
I was just good at it and they loved me.
And I just on this track to be a lawyer.
And I was going to apply to law school, whatever.
I don't know.
Anyway.
Yeah, I mean, it's wild to know that, yeah.
Yeah, it didn't happen, and I decided to, like, go sleep on the dance.
我不知道。我就是擅长这个，而且他们都很喜欢我。我本来已经走上了成为律师的轨道。我打算申请法学院什么的。不管怎样。是的，我的意思是，得知这些真的很疯狂。是的，后来没有发生，我决定去舞蹈室睡觉。
I needed somewhere to go when me and my mom had a big falling out.
And I called the dance teacher, and I said, you know, can I come stay?
I'll sleep on the couch at the dance studio.
And he said, yeah.
That's crazy.
He liked me, but yeah.
Do you still have a talent for numbers and bookkeeping and that types of things?
Like, are you involved with your?
我和我妈闹翻后，我需要找个地方去。我给舞蹈老师打电话，我说，我能去借住吗？我睡舞蹈室的沙发就行。他说，可以。太疯狂了。他挺喜欢我的，不过是的。你现在对数字、簿记这类事情还有天赋吗？比如你会参与你的……
Or do you just kind of just let you just...
No, I'm smart about it, but I...
And I've always been very attuned with my biz managers,
like not to let my money get away from me.
But you're not like playing the markets and like, you know,
looking on the stock pages and like...
I do some investing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
还是你只是放手让……不，在这方面我很精明，而且，我一直和我的商务经纪人配合得很紧密，不让我的钱莫名其妙流失。但你不是那种去炒股、看股票行情页面的人吧……我确实做一些投资。对，对，对，对。
Because like some people I know, they really like,
they handicap companies, kind of like horses
and they really follow that.
Yeah, no, I don't.
I don't.
But I, and I left that behind and probably can, you know,
do multiplication. Now, my kids' math
因为就像我认识的一些人，他们真的很喜欢研究公司，就像赛马一样，他们真的很关注这些。是的，不，我不会。我不会。我不会。不过，我把那些抛在脑后了，可能（现在）还会做乘法。现在，我孩子们的数学
is too hard for me when I try to help
them. You know what I just read the other day?
They should be good.
The keeping tree?
A page of a book?
They don't teach cursive
anymore in school. I haven't done
for like the last few years. I know. Why is
对我来说太难了，当我尝试辅导他们时。你知道我前几天读到了什么吗？他们应该挺擅长的。树长得很慷慨？一页书？他们在学校里不再教草书了。过去几年一直没教。我知道。为什么会这样？
that? Well, I guess because typing
is such a big part of... We don't write anymore.
But you've got to sign your name and stuff.
Exactly. Like, what is a signature?
They teach them their name in kindergarten, I think,
and that's it.
And that's it. We're done.
Next chapter.
嗯，我猜是因为打字占据了很大的比重……我们不再手写了。但你还得签名什么的。没错。签名到底是什么？我想他们大概在幼儿园教他们写自己的名字，然后就没了。就这。结束了。进入下一篇章。
How's everybody's handwriting?
Self-assessment on your handwriting.
Oh, it's terrible because you don't get to practice it.
The worst?
Jason Badge.
My brain works faster than my hand, so I can't, you know.
I also want to have to write a birthday card.
I'm like, it's horrendous.
大家的字写得怎么样？评估一下你们自己的字迹。噢，太糟糕了，因为你根本没机会练习。谁的最烂？杰森·贝吉。我的大脑运转得比手快，所以我不能，你知道。我还得写生日卡片。我觉得，这太可怕了。
Wait a minute.
Like, I have to cross shit out.
It's crazy.
Do you do all caps?
I do like a hybrid.
It's terrible.
Yeah, me too.
It's a hybrid.
等一下。比如，我得把错字划掉。这太疯狂了。你全写大写字母吗？我用的是混合体。太糟糕了。是的，我也是。是混合体。
Yeah.
I'll start every sentence in cursive and then end up going,
just for legibility.
alone. I want people to understand what the hell I'm writing.
It's so true.
Okay, so this is like, I'm going to just because we're almost at a time with you.
Speed round, speed round, speed round, speed round.
So we're going to do like a little tiny something speed round.
对。我每一句开头都用草书，然后写着写着就变成正楷了，纯粹是为了可读性。我希望人们能看懂我到底在写什么鬼东西。太真实了。好了，因为我们快没时间了。快问快答，快问快答，快问快答，快问快答。所以我们要来一个微型的快问快答环节。
If you, if you, we didn't even get to your like, to your music career, which is just
massive.
And I've been to, I know every other song that you've ever recorded.
And I just think it's incredible.
I mean, what you've accomplished.
You know, it's pretty insane.
I just had a number one dance record.
Like a few weeks ago
如果你，如果你——我们甚至还没聊到你的音乐生涯，那是极其庞大的。我听过，我知道你录过的每一首歌。我真的觉得这太不可思议了。我的意思是，你所取得的成就。你知道，这相当疯狂。我刚刚才出了一首排名第一的舞曲。就在几周前，
Yes
I had a new record out
Called Save Me Tonight
And I went and I performed it at Coachella
And after that I went to number one
That's amazing
It's amazing
It is amazing
是的，我有一首新歌叫《今夜救我》。我去科切拉音乐节表演了这首歌。在那之后它就冲到了第一名。这太惊人了。太惊人了。这真的很惊人。
Had you done Coachella before?
Never
It was my first time at Coachella
Was it was it a freaky big experience
Or was it
It's massive
It's big
And it's I had never been
你以前去过科切拉吗？从来没有。那是我第一次去科切拉。那是一次令人疯狂的巨大体验吗？还是说它非常宏大。很大。而且我从来没去过。
I didn't know what it was like
Or whatever
But you have all these people
And I hadn't done a dance record a long time, and David Getta had this record.
And I was going out on tour last summer to do like a little limited tour overseas.
And I was like, I need some new songs.
Like I'm tired of performing the same whole songs.
So I did like five new records.
我不知道那是什么样的，诸如此类。但你有那么多的观众，而且我已经很久没发过舞曲了，大卫·库塔（David Guetta）有这首歌。我去年夏天要出去巡演，在海外做一个小型的限量巡演。我当时想：我需要一些新歌。我厌倦了总是表演那些老歌。所以我做了大约五首新歌。
By the way, we're not tired of this song.
Thank you.
I still do them.
I did like five new records, three or four, yeah, four or five new records.
And I put them in the show.
just for that.
And this one kind of popped off.
顺便说一句，我们可没听腻那些歌。谢谢你们。我还在唱。我还在唱。我做了大约五首新歌，三四首，对，四五首新歌。我把它们放进演出里。就为了那个。而这首歌突然就火了。
And so we released it a couple months ago or something.
And what about videos?
People still make videos, right?
They do.
But it's not the same.
Yeah, I don't really even feel like I need to sometimes.
Do you have to pay for them?
所以我们在几个月前左右发布了它。那MV呢？人们还在拍MV，对吧？拍的。他们拍。但已经不一样了。是的，有时候我甚至觉得没必要。你还得自掏腰包拍吗？
I do.
Yeah, because it's different.
Like when I started, they'd spend millions of dollars on videos, like a million dollars,
$2 million dollars with big budget videos.
You know, Michael Jackson, Jan.
used to do like $7 million videos, you know.
But now, because of streaming and how the record business has changed since I started,
it's like a whole different world.
我得掏。是的，因为现在不一样了。当我刚出道时，他们会在MV上花数百万美元，比如100万美元、200万美元的大制作MV。你知道的，迈克尔·杰克逊，詹恩。以前经常拍那种700万美元的MV，你知道的。但现在，因为流媒体和自从我出道以来唱片业的变化，这完全是一个不同的世界了。
You have to shoot them on your iPhone, yourself, $100,000.
Sometimes they give you $75.
It's really a different thing.
And that's to promote the album that you have a...
Probably through social media, too.
Yeah.
Right.
And it's not even your album.
你得用iPhone自己拍，花10万美元。有时候他们只给你7.5万美元。这确实是完全不同的情况。而那是为了宣传你拥有的专辑……可能也是通过社交媒体。对。而且甚至都不是你的专辑。
It's the labels album.
And the way the music industry runs nowadays, correct me,
most of the income for the artist comes from touring
as opposed to album sales.
Is that right?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Now, speaking of touring, you've done,
是唱片公司的专辑。以现在音乐产业的运作方式，纠正我一下，艺人的大部分收入来自于巡演，而不是专辑销量，对吗？绝对是的。现在，说到巡演，你已经巡演了，
you two it forever.
You didn't obviously massive, massive shows your whole life.
You know I love horrible theater stories.
You might not know this, but give me something
that happened on a tour that just went horribly wrong.
That's funny.
Well, I don't know if you saw this.
Oh, yes, I know what you're going to say.
你们永远都在巡演。你一生中显然做过无数场、规模巨大的演出。你知道我喜欢听灾难性的剧场故事。你可能不知道这一点，但给我讲讲巡演中某个彻底搞砸了的故事吧。这很有趣。嗯，我不知道你有没有看到过这个。噢，是的，我知道你要说什么了。
I know what you're going to say.
The thing on my net.
Did you see it?
No, I saw it.
when you fell.
No, that happened.
But that wasn't on tour.
That was on television.
我知道你要说什么。我脖子上的那个东西。你看到了吗？不，我看到了。你摔倒的时候。不，那是那次。但那不是在巡演中。那是在电视上。
Oh, that's right.
And it ran on CNN for the next three days.
My fucking coxics was fucking on fire.
Right.
It was just like, it was awful.
But no, I was going to say this summer on tour.
I was.
I just wrote three jokes.
噢，对。接下来的三天里那段视频在CNN上循环播放。我的尾椎骨简直痛得要命。对。简直糟透了。不过，不，我是想说今年夏天巡演的时候。我，我刚刚写了三个笑话。
Sorry.
I'm not doing any of them.
There's a coxics on fire and we need to take pills for it and all this.
Never mind.
Yes.
This summer when I was on tour,
I don't remember where I was.
Oh, God, which actual date it was.
抱歉。我一个都不讲了。尾椎骨痛得要命，我们得吃止痛药之类的。算了。是的。今年夏天我巡演的时候，我不记得我在哪儿了。噢，天哪，到底是哪一场。
But I was there and I was, I might have been in Spain
because I was singing a Spanish song.
And it was like the slow moment in the show, you know,
although usually I'm dancing around and doing the choreography
and like a fucking bikini and a G-string.
Right? Right.
Whipping my hair around and it's a good time.
And so I'm standing.
但我当时在那儿，我可能在西班牙，因为我在唱一首西班牙语歌。那是演出中比较舒缓的时刻，你知道的，尽管通常我都在到处跳舞，跳着编排好的舞蹈，穿着性感比基尼和G弦裤。对吧？对吧？疯狂甩着头发，玩得很开心。所以我站在那里。
Same, same.
Yeah.
And so I'm standing.
there fully dressed and I have this thing on. It's like outfit on and I'm singing and it's really
quiet. It's just a spotlight on me and I don't know like all during the show I was seeing like
little bugs and things around but you know we're outside. Oh this I did see that. They're attracted
to the light. Yeah. And so everything is dark except for me and I'm singing and as I'm singing
and as I'm singing the audience starts screaming and usually they do react in this moment because
一样，一样。是的。所以我站在那里，穿得整整齐齐，身上穿着这套衣服，我在唱歌，现场非常安静。只有一束聚光灯打在我身上，我不知道，在整场演出中我看到周围有一些小虫子之类的，但你知道我们在室外。噢，这个我看到了。它们被光吸引了。对。所以周围一片漆黑，只有我是亮的，我在唱歌，正当我唱着唱着，观众开始尖叫，通常他们在这个时刻会有所反应，因为
I stop and it's a slow song and they usually clap and whatever before I do the little last
line. I do like a dramatic pause. But this time they're like clapping a lot and screaming.
And I was like, what's happening? And I'm just there. And this huge bug is just crawling up my neck.
And I feel it. And I thought it was hitting me and going away and hitting me and going away.
But when you see the thing, it's just, it starts like down here and it just goes.
Yeah.
And it lands up right here.
And I just feel it a little bit.
我停下来了，这是一首慢歌，通常在我唱最后一句之前他们会鼓掌什么的。我会做一个戏剧性的停顿。但这一次他们一直在鼓掌和尖叫。我当时想：发生什么事了？我就站在那儿。然后一只巨大的虫子正顺着我的脖子往上爬。我感觉到了。我以为它撞了我一下就飞走了，撞了我一下又飞走了。但当你回看视频时，它从这里开始，然后它就一直。对。最后停在了这里。我隐约感觉到了。
But I was, I just stayed really still.
And I finished the song, the last line.
And then I just go.
And I kind of go.
And it flies into the light like that.
And I saw it.
I was like, what the fuck was that?
Yeah.
但我，我只是保持一动不动。我唱完了这首歌的最后一句。然后我只是。我做了一个动作。它就这样飞向了灯光。我看到了。我当时想：那特么到底是什么东西？对。
It looked like a helicopter.
It was crazy.
I love that.
But that was crazy.
But it was kind of horrible.
Like if I would have known it was that, I probably would have just screaming and yelling.
No, no.
Okay, three final little things.
看起来像架直升机。太疯狂了。我喜欢这样。但这太疯狂了。但这也挺可怕的。如果我当时知道那是这玩意儿，我可能已经尖叫大喊了。不，不。好吧，最后三个小问题。
What's the most Bronx thing about you
that's never left a matter where life is taking?
I can't stop cursing.
I try.
Okay, great. I love that.
I have potty mouth.
It's terrible.
I love it.
无论生活带你去到哪里，你身上最具有“布朗克斯特色”且从未改变的是什么？我戒不掉骂脏话。我试过了。好的，太棒了。我太喜欢了。我满嘴脏话。太糟糕了。我太喜欢了。
And then, by the way, I'm telling you know this, Jen already,
but I'm saying to Jason and Will,
did you guys know that Google images
is because of Jennifer Lopez?
What do you mean?
That Google didn't have Google images
until that green Versacee dress.
And then everybody Googled it.
而且，顺便说一句，我知道詹妮弗已经知道了，但我得跟杰森和威尔说，你们知道谷歌图片是因为詹妮弗·洛佩兹才诞生的吗？什么意思？就是因为那件绿色的范思哲礼服，谷歌之前是没有谷歌图片的。然后大家都去搜它。
So then Google's like,
we don't have anywhere for people
to see images. A search engine. So they invented Google images
because of Jennifer Lopez. Isn't that wild? And Sergey, Sergey has
you know, that he's been asked that after that. He's like, yes, that is absolutely true.
Jennifer, when she walked the red carpet in that dress, everybody wanted to
have a picture of it and we didn't have any Google search picks anything.
So we invented it.
所以当时谷歌就想，我们没有地方能让大家看图片。一个搜索引擎。于是他们因为詹妮弗·洛佩兹发明了谷歌图片。这不是很疯狂吗？谢尔盖，谢尔盖你知道的，事后有人问过他。他说，是的，绝对是这样的。詹妮弗穿着那件裙子走红毯时，每个人都想看它的照片，而我们当时没有任何谷歌搜索图片的功能。所以我们发明了它。
Sue them, sue them. They're so rich. I was like, don't I deserve some money for that?
For sure, for sure. We got some good lawyers.
Okay. And then we got to do.
Got to plug this because I can't wait to see it.
Office Romance comes out June 5th on Netflix.
It does.
Yes, you, Brett Goldstein.
He wrote it with you in mind.
告他们，告他们。他们那么有钱。我当时就想，难道我不该因此得到一些钱吗？当然，当然。我们有很好的律师。好了。然后我们得做这个。必须宣传一下，因为我已经迫不及待想看了。《办公室浪漫》将于6月5日在Netflix上线。确实如此。是的，你，布雷特·戈尔德斯坦。他写剧本的时候就是照着你写的。
Yes, he did.
Super funny, Brett Goldstein.
He's funny, but I love his brand.
His brand of writing where it's like really kind of hard jokes,
but with this wholesomeness at the end of the day.
It's just, it's really, I think you guys will like this one.
Okay, good.
I can't wait for guys and girls, not just the romantic comedy for like girls.
是的，没错。超级搞笑，布雷特·戈尔德斯坦。他很搞笑，但我喜欢他的风格。他的写作风格是那种非常犀利的笑话，但到最后又带有一种纯真温暖的感觉。真的，我觉得你们会喜欢这部作品的。好的，太好了。我等不及了，不仅仅是那种给女孩看的浪漫喜剧。
And then this is really cool.
Edward James Olmos, who was your dad in Selena, is your dad in this movie?
He is.
And I got to tell you, when we filmed with him and he walks in on this, like, board meeting.
And it's the first time you see him.
And when he walks in, like, all the cast and all the extras that were in the board meeting were like, you know, kind of like, he has such a commanding presence.
But even more than that, when we screamed it for the first time, and he walks in and his first line is hot.
damn with that really deep voice and people just started clapping in the theater and i get
然后这个真的很酷。爱德华·詹姆斯·奥莫斯，他在《赛琳娜》里演你的爸爸，在这部电影里演你的爸爸吗？是的。我得告诉你们，当我们跟他一起拍戏时，他走进这个董事会会议室。那是你第一次见到他。当他走进来时，所有演员和在董事会会议室里的所有群众演员都，你知道，就好像，他有一种非常强大的气场。但更厉害的是，当我们第一次试映时，他走进来，他的第一句台词是“真他妈的”，用那种非常低沉的声音，剧院里的观众就开始鼓掌，我……
and i think part because he was my dad and selina of course but also because it's just like
it's edward james almost you know um and it was great it was great to get to work with him again
he's amazing and speaking of musicals i love kiss of the spider woman i can't believe it was your
first movie musical ever you need to do more and second of all are you i read somewhere you're
going to do bye-bye birdie but that was a while ago that was a while ago that was a while ago that was a while ago
Do you remember when they were doing like these musicals on TV?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
而且我觉得部分原因是因为他在《赛琳娜》里演过我爸爸，当然，但也因为他就是爱德华·詹姆斯·奥莫斯，你知道的，嗯，真的很棒，能再次跟他合作真的很棒，他太棒了。说到音乐剧，我太爱《蜘蛛女之吻》了，真不敢相信那是你拍的第一部电影音乐剧，你得多拍几部。其次，我从哪儿看到消息说你要演《再见，小鸟》，但那是好久以前的事了。那是好久以前了。那是好久以前了。那是好久以前了。你还记得他们以前在电视上搞这种音乐剧的时候吗？哦，对。对。
The NBC.
Are you asking if Sean remembers?
Yeah.
I did Hairspray live with Ariana Grande.
That's right.
So when they did those,
when they were talking about doing bye-bye birdie,
NBC电视台的。你是在问肖恩还记得吗？对。我和爱莉安娜·格兰德一起演了《发胶明星梦》直播。没错。没错。所以当他们做那些节目，当他们谈论要拍《再见，小鸟》时，
but then it kind of went away.
Well, make it happen again.
I don't know.
We'll see.
You'd be great, Rosie.
You'd be a great Rosie.
Trust me, I practiced all the songs.
Well, they could change it to everything is Jay Lo.
但后来这个项目就不了了之了。好吧，让它再次发生吧。我不知道。我们走着瞧。罗茜，你会演得很棒的。你会成为一个很棒的罗茜。相信我，我都把所有的歌练习过了。好吧，他们可以把它改成“一切都是简·洛”。
Yeah, they could.
They could.
All right.
Well, honey,
thank you so much for being here.
You guys are great.
Thank you so much.
It was very cool of you to do this,
对，他们可以。他们可以。好吧，亲爱的，非常感谢你来到这里。你们太棒了。非常感谢。你能来做这个节目真是太酷了，
Jennifer.
Thank you so much.
No, not at all.
Ever since you did it that one day
and I walked into the podcast,
I was like, I've got to do that one day.
That's right.
詹妮弗。非常感谢。不，一点也不。自从你那天做过之后，我走进播客间，我就想，我有一天也一定要来做那个。没错。没错。
Yeah, yeah.
I'm sure you're off to go do something.
What are you doing in New York?
I was doing the up front.
Right now I'm editing.
I'm working on an edit for the,
I just did a residency in Vegas.
and I did a new show, a brand new show, the J-Lo show, which you would love, because what I did was
对，对。我确信你要赶去干别的什么。你在纽约做什么？我当时在做推介会。现在我在剪辑。我在为……我刚在拉斯维加斯驻唱完，然后我做了一个新节目，一个全新的节目，简·洛秀，你会喜欢的，因为我做的是……
combine my hits with musical theater inspirations of mine. I know it sounds like it wouldn't
work, but it worked amazing.
Wait, but it's a, it's a residency where you just...
So we filmed it for Paramount Plus and for CBS, and so I'm editing, we're editing that now.
I can't wait to see that.
Yeah, we filmed it.
Yeah, that's good.
Very cool.
把我的热门歌曲与我的音乐剧灵感结合起来。我知道听起来可能行不通，但效果出奇的好。等等，但这只是一个驻唱……所以我们为派拉蒙+和CBS拍摄了它，所以现在我在剪辑，我们正在剪辑那个。我等不及要看了。对，我们拍了。对，那很好。非常酷。
Busy as ever.
Just doing my thing.
Keep going.
Singing, dancing, show, girl.
It's really so impressive, Jennifer.
It really is.
Keep going.
Thank you.
一如既往地忙碌。做我自己的事。继续前进。唱歌，跳舞，歌舞女郎。真的太让人印象深刻了，詹妮弗。真的。继续加油。谢谢。
It's amazing.
You guys are so kind.
Thank you.
Yes.
We'll see you soon.
I'll see you soon.
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
Bye, honey.
太棒了。你们太好了。谢谢。是的。我们很快再见。我很快会再见。再见，再见，再见，再见，再见。再见，亲爱的。
That's a big star.
Sean, that is a massive, massive talent and star.
I mean, when I was reading about her, it's just, you go, oh, yeah, oh, wait, yeah.
Oh, wait.
You know, that's not a star.
That's a, that's a mega star.
That's a mega star.
That documentary is pretty stunning.
那可真是个大明星。肖恩，那绝对是具有巨大、巨大天赋的巨星。我的意思是，当我读到关于她的资料时，你就会觉得，哦，对，哦，等等，对。哦，等等。你知道，那可不只是个明星。那是超级巨星。那是超级巨星。那部纪录片相当震撼。
I mean, it takes you all the way through it.
Everything that she's done.
Who can do, who does all of it?
Yeah, yeah.
But it's also so incredibly well earned.
It's not, it's not because, you know,
there's some sort of celebrity manipulation or something.
She's like, she does everything and does it at such a high level.
我的意思是，它带你完整地看了一遍。她所做过的一切。谁能做到，谁能把所有这些都包揽？对，对。但这也是她当之无愧的。这并不是，并不是因为，你知道的，有什么名人的炒作或类似的东西。她是那种什么都做，而且都做到如此高水平的人。
And people are, you know, paying for it.
And they're supporting it.
And she's just...
And she has this sort of, as I was saying,
like this sort of, this coolness and this calmness
and this, like, knows who she is clearly, right?
And it's, like, so comfortable.
And again, I was kind of getting at that thing
而人们也，你知道的，愿意为此买单。他们在支持她。她就是……而且她有这样一种，就像我刚才说的，有这样一种，这种酷劲和这种冷静，以及这种，显然很清楚自己是谁的特质，对吧？而且，感觉非常自然。再说一次，我刚才想说的是……
of, like, we all think that we know.
Right.
And who people are.
I remember watching...
Remember that Tiger Woods documentary came out a few years ago?
Oh, so well.
And it started...
And I remember turning it off because I was thinking,
那种，就是，我们都以为我们了解。没错。而且知道人们是什么样的。我记得我看过……还记得几年前上映的那个泰格·伍兹的纪录片吗？哦，印象深刻。它开始于……我记得我把它关掉了，因为我在想……
like, I don't think he wants me to know all this stuff.
Do you know what I mean?
Oh, right.
I just turned it off.
I don't know all that stuff?
But just anything about people,
when any people just talking shit,
就像，我觉得他可能不想让我知道所有这些事情。你知道我的意思吗？哦，对。我直接关掉了。我直接关掉了。我不知道所有那些事情？但只要是关于人们的任何事，当有人在那儿胡说八道时，
like we don't know anything about it.
Oh, I thought he was in it.
I thought you were saying it.
No, no, no.
Until we hear from them what their experiences,
we don't really know.
And she does seem so purposefully aware of her beginnings,
of her roots,
就像我们对它一无所知一样。哦，我还以为他在里面呢。我还以为你在说他呢。不，不，不。直到我们听到他们亲口讲述他们的经历，我们才真正了解。而她似乎非常刻意地意识到自己的出身，自己的根，
and is constantly staying in touch with the people
that she surrounds herself with.
Yeah.
And so that's probably what she's so on it.
Shawnee, I mean, that was a great get.
Oh, I'm so happy.
And there's no way you would be lazy to work in the bye-bye birdie thing at the end there of your questioning.
I didn't even thought about it.
并且一直在与她身边的人保持联系。对。所以这就是为什么她做事总是那么游刃有余。肖尼，我的意思是，能请到她真是一次伟大的邀约。哦，我太高兴了。而且你绝不会偷懒到在提问的最后硬扯上《再见，小鸟》的话题。我甚至都没想过这个。
No, no.
Plus, I think you've used by-by-burty before.
Many times.
Yeah, I would never use the game.
We'll just wait.
We'll wait for something a little bit better.
Yeah, I know that you need a Google search or something.
Yeah, if there's something that needs to come up, you know what I mean, that you had it thought of.
不，不。而且，我觉得你以前也用过“再见，小鸟”这个梗。很多次。对，我绝不会用这个梗。我们再等等。我们等一个稍微好一点的。对，我知道你需要一个谷歌搜索什么的。对，如果有事情需要提出来，你知道我的意思，你是没想到的。
Well, the bye-by-by-Burdy thing is real because she,
She was going to do it.
No, we know it's real, but maybe if there was something...
You can't set yourself up like that.
No, yeah.
You know what I mean?
There's got to be something typing and just trying to think.
Well, you guys know from her album, This Is Me?
好吧，“再见，小鸟”这事是真的，因为她，她本来打算演的。不，我们知道是真的，但也许如果有别的事……你不能给自己挖这种坑。不，对。你知道我的意思吗？总得有些打字的东西，然后试着想想。好吧，你们从她的专辑《这就是我》里知道了……
Sure.
Yeah, of course, yeah.
Oh, my favorite.
What do you...
You mean her 2002 record, This Is Me?
Yeah.
This is me then, yeah.
当然。对，当然，对。哦，我的最爱。你……你是说她2002年的唱片《这就是我》？对。对。这就是当年的我，对。
And you guys know...
This is me now?
Yeah, this is me now.
Yeah, this is...
You have a favorite song for that album?
Yeah, it's so good.
It's called.
never it's called never a good
然后你们知道……《这就是我：现在》？对，这就是我：现在。对，这是……你这张专辑里有最喜欢的歌吗？对，太棒了。它叫……从来不，它叫……从来没有一个好……
bye
you sneaky son of a
bye birdie
oh
you are so bad
smart less
smartless is 100%
organic and artisanly
再见，你这个鬼鬼祟祟的《再见，小鸟》的混蛋。哦，你太坏了。SmartLess。SmartLess是100%有机且由手工匠人制作的。
handcrafted by
Rob Armjarf Bennett
Barbacob and Michael Grand Terry
Smartless
由罗布·阿姆贾夫、贝内特·巴尔巴科布和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作。SmartLess